Hello, hello everybody!
If you are here right now, you didn't get raptured!
And you're now stuck with me forever!
That's right, you committed the biggest sin!
Watching an anime VTuber and it's too late to stop now!
Yay!
Wait, wait, wait.
That's right!
You didn't get raptured.
You're here.
You're still here.
And it's so wrong.
And why does it feel so right?
Oh, yeah, for those who are very confused right now, apparently, there's been an on Christian TikTok.
I know, wild.
But people were.
saying that people were predicting today is the day where all the all the good people will get raptured so like leading up to today people were posting tiktoks about like what do you do when you get raptured tips on how to handle the rapture and and then um it was supposed to happen at like around 11 30 a.m or some shit and people were like people were like trying to be like oh it's because they're doing it one at a time so it's gonna take a while to like get there because they're like they're like wait why are we getting raptured right now it's being like oh don't worry it's just taking they're just doing it one at a time uh so it's just very slow you know it's not an instant rapture there's a queue yeah there's a fucking line right now for the rapture but no you did it you're stuck here you you committed sin so now you're here and all you can do is just watch me yeah you weren't special enough i knew i wasn't getting raptured i did a lot i we all got left i i knew i wasn't like i i
was ready to stream today I was like, okay, to be fair, I was debating whether or not to stream today because, um, because I was, uh, I was very tired.
I had a really bad sleep today.
Um, so, because I don't know, I went to bed around like 10 in the morning because I couldn't fall asleep.
I also had like, it was very stressful because like, um, uh, I had, there was like sponsor issues because, uh, because I know some people were like, oh, I'm just supposed to do a collab for your sponsor, stuff happened and um Nikolai partner had to pull up because like some personal stuff happened so like throughout that time I think like I had to be awake to figure out like oh like I had to find like a backup plan being like oh my gosh like who else can we bring in like this last minute like for tomorrow because it's like one of the sponsors we it was planned for a while now um so we're like fuck okay we gotta figure out like can we bring someone over this last minute and also take the same amount of payment that the my letter collab partner took and so like um it was hard because like uh we couldn't we had to figure this out within last night so i was awake till seven in the morning trying to figure out a solution and in the end um um we're uh we're like can i just do it solo and
because like we can't like it was either this or i or i joined another group but like I felt so awkward because there were some people that I've never collabed with before or like really had an interaction before so I didn't want to like I didn't want to have like an awkward collab situation where I forced myself onto of another group like just join them like last minute so they're like oh so we're just like okay how about I just do a solo and they're like you know yeah fuck it it's it's so there wasn't there's not a lot of stuff we could do about it so uh so i don't want me a new person via sponsor you know i rather get to know a person before i like do a sponsor with them so i rather just meet i rather have that interaction first um so and i didn't want to force them to be like hey hey here's jokie bird remember when you're supposed to do a collab with one person you got collab with her too and i felt like that would be so awkward So I was just like,
but I'll just do it solo.
Because we have to figure this out late at night.
And at that point, everyone's asleep, you know, because it's NA hours.
But like, obviously, like, the client wasn't NA.
So, like, for them, they're all awake.
But for me, it's, like, everyone's asleep.
So I couldn't grab something.
Like, I can, like, message somebody late at night and be like, can you do it?
And then, you know, all the legal stuff as well.
So now I was just like, okay.
And then after that, I was just so stressed out about that.
That was like tossing and turning to like 10, I think like 10 in the morning.
And then like, and then I went to sleep.
I went to bed.
And I think I woke up around basically at like 3.30 p.m.
Because I was just, my brain was just too, at that point my brain was just too active.
So I couldn't go to bed.
So I was like, oh fuck, do I stream?
It's so late already.
You know, I was like, oh, I didn't make, I didn't post my schedule.
So like, it would be so last minute.
day I have to I need people because that'll be like what did people think I got raptured like I was just like I can't do that I need people to know if i haven't got right if you know that I'm still here I so so I was like I got a stream today or people won't know they need to know that I'm still here so I was stream something today it would be what do you mean it would be crazy if i did get raptured hello at least i didn't murder anyone i've always i've always repented i looked at my mini confessional and be like please forgive me like where is that supposed to mean i could have been raptured not that bad of a person i i didn't murder anyone yet uh whoever yes thank you for the magenta soup but thank you thank you worth it next thing thank you super chat thank you thank you i say this is better than heaven but probably change my mind by a time we're an hour in thank you for the super chat thank you thank you uh uh see luca thank you the magenta soup but thank you thank you has to just
enjoy Halo.
Halo 2 is so good, but rage-inducing is to go same level as New Vegas.
No, I haven't played Halo 2 yet, but I definitely did enjoy Halo 1.
We'll go back to Halo 2 soon.
I just, also, like, thinking about it, I think, like, started, after I finished Sleeping Dogs, we're just gonna commit to one series a week.
Doing two series, just too much.
Because I keep forgetting.
I keep having to remember trolls because I have to like finish like do two series at once so I'm gonna like do one series so I thought to be fair I was doing one series a week until like Holland night came up and his silk song came up so then like it's sort of like messed up my entire like rhythm so it's easier for me to focus on one series a week this time um but definitely yeah definitely after after when if we finish leaping dogs that's where we're pivoting to and then we could just do like random stuff in between um what else do i want to say um oh yeah apparently silent hill early access came out i'm guys remember i'm not playing until a million subscribers but um so i still have a lot of time i might have until like next halloween uh but i heard about i was watching i watched a little bit up Silent Hill F and um and I I from because like uh Charlie was playing it's like it was it just popped up in my on my twitch feed so I was like I'll check it out just to see I didn't really
get spoiled I just wanted to see how it looks it definitely feels a lot different than um the Silent Hill 2 remastered it apparently it's more so Japanese horror because it's all set in Japan so it focused and then apparently people were saying it's the dark souls of they were saying they were saying it's the dark souls of silent hill because there's like dodge mechanics now so like you can actually like iframe dodges and so and i was like that's pretty funny i it was yeah like um like apparently there's i frames when you're dodging in silent hill f so they're like it's the dark souls of silent hill and you can you can roll Oh my god,
you can roll.
That's crazy.
Yeah, you can eye-frame your jump scares now.
But, uh, but everyone, but it is a lot, it is, it's a lot, I don't know if I say it a lot scarier.
I was watching it a little bit.
Uh, but, uh, oh, you cat roll.
Someone was like, you can roll.
I was like, wait, you cat?
I just saw her dodging.
I didn't realize.
It's just more so of like, shimmy, shimmy dodges.
But it looks, it's a lot different.
It's a lot different from Silent Hill 2 Remastered.
Because I think it's like, it's different developers too, I'm pretty sure, right?
Because like Silent Hill 2 Remastered came from that painting horror game developer.
I don't remember what they're called.
The one that did the painting, the scary painting game.
And then Silent Hill, this Silent Hill F was developed by in Japan.
like by the um what's the word called by the um you know i don't know what it's called like back back in the core development team in the in the core development i think bluebird team did only did the remaster so it was uh sorry like i said my brain is really tired right now because i didn't have a really good oh it's a chinese developer i thought it was in japan um okay it wasn't yeah I thought oh it was still yeah I was gonna say I thought it was it was a Japanese development team because it's based in uh jap like it's based in like Japanese lore and uh based in Japanese lore and the writer of the game was by when they cry so I didn't realize it was Chinese developer team so I guess they also outsourged it to a different uh development team then um but it I don't know it doesn't look that scary to me because like that's because like silent hill uh two fucking freaks me out um it was like it was it like gave me goosebumps and i actually had like had like uh my heart was just beating
so fucking fast when i was playing silent hill too but when i was watched but then i'm like saying i'm watching it watching it is different from actually playing it as we all know um because we're like oh when you're watching something hey it's not that scary but when you're actually playing it it's like freaking freaky but i'm not sure i I think it's also because it's not as dark.
I think that's it.
Because like when you're, but then she's like mostly, even when she was inside, it didn't seem like she was in a dark environment.
While in Silent Hill 2, I felt like, I was like, where the fuck am I?
Like, I felt like I'm always shining my flashlights everywhere.
I was like, where am I?
I was like, where is this?
I can't see, I can't see within one meter.
Like, I look up, I'm like, where is this?
like when I was watching Silent Hill F I was like wow I can see everything like I'm like wow it's not just pitch black holy fuck like so so I feel like that's promising for me because that means I won't be like extra freaked out um um but yeah uh it seems really fun people were saying very different so if you did enjoy the Silent Hill franchise um you might not like the newest game only because it's not very faithful to like the original it's not based it's not like the original mechanics of the it doesn't follow the usual formula of a Silent Hill game so people were just saying like oh um it is new you might not like it because it is new like it's following a new um and uh and like uh just new there's a new way of playing silent hill so i think that's very interesting simple-minded thank you for the super chat thank you thank you doki no offense but you get raptured then there's a good chance everyone in chat would hey i have i have a secret murderer i don't okay okay if you're okay i
shouldn't say that but uh but if you are a secret murderer watching my please turn yourself in please turn yourself in oh I'm sorry you I do not I'm sorry if you're a dragoon I'm so I have legally I have to disown you as a drag I really don't want to be connected to any crimes legally I will have to call the cops on you I do not want to be associated with any murderers but thank you for the super chat thank you thank you black fire welcome Thank you for the five gifts and chips.
Thank you.
She was a fan of you first thing.
I am not defending a murderer.
I would get like X amount.
I'm not going to be on the news being like, beach.
I swear to God.
If you are a murderer and you get caught, before you get caught, burn all your Doki merch.
I am not getting on the news because you were a Doki Bird fan.
I am not going to be.
I'm like, we've uncovered a JokieB championship, like we've uncovered this, and these anime Vtuber merch in the suspects.
I don't do this to me.
Don't, don't, don't fucking do this to me.
I, this is not, you don't wanna say all exposure is good.
This is not good exposure.
This is not good.
If you are a JokieBrie fan and you commit murder, Burn all your... Just throw it away.
Throw it away.
I am not getting on the news.
This is not the reason why I want to get on the news.
I do not want this.
Because this is not good marketing.
I do not want to be on fucking CNN.
It was like my merch plastered on there.
Mr. Mr. McFluffikens.
Here he goes.
Why do we still watch this?
streamer it's just if you're a murderer it's that's like that's like my i have so little rules i i like i just have so little rules i tolerate so much but oh murdering is just too far like wow thank you for the super chat thank you thank you remember you're gonna do crime wait for your new genus draws where to arrive Not endorsed by Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway, other than that, um, also, I don't know if you guys heard, but there is a new Daft Punk, um, there's a new Daft Punk collab with Fortnite.
I know we've been, like, expecting that for a while.
Like, they've been teasing it for the longest time.
But we finally have a confirmed date, uh, and it's gonna be this Saturday, and I'm super fucking excited.
The only thing I'm like a little bit of like I don't step out a little bit Sad about is that it's not a concert concert.
It's an experience I have no idea what the fuck that meant means, but From the leaks it's like basically like a map and you get to go through like various rooms and stuff That's like related to daft punk and you get to like experience like daft punk music in like different rooms in different ways The only also my other issue about this is that it's in the morning who the fuck right like I said before who the fuck raves in the morning I'm just like why is it in the morning if I'm going to a rave it won't be when the sun is up Like it's like 10 30 in the Saturday morning like what is this for kid like What is it about a four kids channel?
It's in the Saturday morning cartoon shit like it's at 10 30 and starts at 11 a.m and it's for the eu people like god damn it how could my fucking french robots do this to me like why mr eu we and they love some too um fortnite was made in america i should get american hours god damn
but yeah how dare the french not cater to me what about quip and qua what about quip back we already we did so much for you a solid thank you for the super chat thank you thank you subscribe to do the keyword um next scene thank you for the Super chat,
thank you, thank you.
That's like my other gripe of, uh, you're not even, bro.
Yeah, but we allow them to be here.
Like, um, we are a bilingual country where we speak French and English.
So, like, we're doing so much for them.
So I feel like they should cater to us.
We could have been, we could have just spoken one official language, but we decided to do too because we're because kanda is like the it's part it's like um the child from a divorced family and we have to like go from like both parents have custody does share custody of us uh kong good thank you for the super chat thank you thank you uh
all right anyway but yeah i'm super excited i've been looking forward to i actually freaked out so happy to find out, like, to see the skins.
Like, oh my God, the skins look so good.
I think the only thing I'm sad about is that they didn't do their classic era, the one with the, okay, I know it looks like, like, their, the outfit looks like, looks incredibly dumb, but, like, the helmets were so good.
The classic era with the LEDs and the rainbow stuff on the helmets, I was so sad that they didn't um include that in the costume pack i think they only did like um or even i wish they included the tron outfit too the tron outfits are really good yeah uh i'm really sad they didn't do the outfit where the helmets are like leds and rainbows and stuff i wish they included that um but they did include the grammy's outfit and the one with the leather jackets and i think i don't remember which ones else they did but i was so happy about that anyway by the way if you are gonna or like elf or any cosmetics on fortnite i do have a uh do you have a creator code it is jokey bird um it does help out a lot because instead of the money going towards fortnite some of it goes to me um and fortnite or fortnite already has enough you know fortnite already has enough so it supports me as well um but yeah i'm super excited uh for the event i honestly don't know They said it's not gonna be a concert.
It's not gonna be a regular concert.
So it's gonna be like Very interesting to like Um To I don't know I feel like it's gonna be very interesting because if they try to clarify like Oh, it's not a regular concert That means it's a its own very unique it's a unique experience.
So I don't know what to expect I really don't know what to expect for it, but I'm just happy that we get something, you know Like, like, you know, okay too young to uh to go to the alive 2000 i actually had to look it up i was like when was the last time they've ever done a tour and then i looked at it was like 2007 and then i remember waiting because i was like well i was too young i was like way too young to go but i still i at that time i i actually really like that fun music too um and you know years pass and like next time they do ready i'll have money i'll like beg my parents to take me there i'll have the money for it uh like i don't care if it's a school day i'm gonna be there and then there were rumors that they're gonna do like a 2017 like you know 10 year anniversary um of their uh last tour everyone was like oh it's gonna happen alive 2017 that's when they are gonna do it and then 2017 passed and then In 2001,
they fucking exploded and died.
A video showed up on the Daft Punk channel.
It was a premiere.
Everyone was so excited.
This is it.
This is when they're going to announce the tour.
And then they did a countdown on a premiere video thinking it was, everyone thinking it was an announcement to their next tour.
robots showed up and it fucking exploded and died and then they're like we're retiring everyone's like what came out of fucking nowhere they're like yeah nowhere where it just they just died they just exploded and they're like retired and everyone's like what including me i was like you what what do you mean excuse me you can't just fucking explode that what you did a tron movie i watched tron for you how could you do this to me i watched tron for you
that's how i'm gonna graduate i'll make a premiere and i'm gonna fucking explode good thank you man welcome to tomato farm welcome you know damn well 80% of people that watch tron legacy was for that you know you know fucking damn well hey we all we were all there for their five minute it wasn't even five minute they were for their fucking two minute cameo and like and we were satisfied we I was satisfied with their two minute cameo I was like this is the greatest movie I've ever watched this is the greatest movie I've ever watched in my life for that two minutes two minutes of death like yeah I heard about their nude their new sorry i have to say their new that i heard about the new tron move it looks so ass i'm sorry it looks so fucking ass like i think it's also because like what's his name god what's his name in that tron movie new oh my god oh yeah mr beast does a cameo too which is pretty fun tron eras oh my god is it playing now no it's on october 9th um I cannot see Jared Leto
as a serious actor anymore.
I think ever since, ever since the Joker, like when he was the Joker, and in all the crazy shit he does during the filming of that Joker, the Batman movie.
Oh, no, it was Suicide Squad.
Ever since he was the Joker and the suicide squad and the shit he did, I can't see him the same.
He's just such a fucking weirdo.
Like, such a weirdo.
He like, okay, for those who don't know, I've talked about it before.
Yes, Jared Leto is the, I guess, I'll say his main actor.
Yeah, he started a Jesus cult, too, by the way.
It's also that I forgot about that.
He started a fucking cult, too.
But for those who don't know what he did during the filming of Suicide, that Suicide Squad, he did a lot of filming for it.
And then they cut, apparently they cut 80% of all the stuff he filmed for.
and then like during during the filming he got like super into the character he was like method acting and stuff so he sent like sex toys to his co-stars as a joke and and what was it used condoms i don't remember that i don't remember about the condoms part but i knew i remember the the sex toys yeah like the co-stars were like yeah um It was so fucking weird because like Jared would just I would just receive packages from Jared And it would just be like A dildo I was just like what?
It's like yeah apparently it was like Method acting and stuff I'm like that's not method acting That's just like That's just being a freak I don't think I don't think I don't think the real Joker would send sex toys I don't I'm like I know I read a lot of joker media and i don't i don't think he ever said sex toys to like batman i don't
i don't think he'd do that to batman i think he'd send like maybe like a jack in the box and be like ha ha but i don't think he went too far as to send a fucking dildo yeah that's not that's not joking he's just yeah i don't think joker is that much of a degenerate he's a murderer yes but i don't think he was a pervert I don't know there's no rules Batman I don't know I don't know guys maybe I was wrong about maybe I didn't know Batman that well I thought he had more I I don't know I thought he had more standards than that guys I didn't realize he was that you know what I when you said he's like you know a criminal you know I thought it was like the murdering kind of as a criminal not like the of a creep of a criminal.
There's no laws against Pokemon, Batman.
Fudge, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't diss the Mormon.
Oh my god, I forgot he was in Morbius.
I fucking...
Okay, he has not been in any good movies in a long time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Fudge, thank you.
Thank you.
Daniel, thank you for the super chat.
Round up for Morbius.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But anyway.
Yeah, so I forgot he was in Morbius as well.
Oh, no.
I know he was like, I know Joker was like, you know, like act like abusive and stuff like that.
But I'd never realize he was like, I don't know.
I think I don't know.
Jared had his own headcanon about Joker.
Because I know, you know, like the whole Harley Quinn with Joker.
thing but he was more so like manipulative like physical abuser like you know that's why harley quinn like left joker for poison ivy um yay quality but um um yeah yeah but i didn't realize like the joker was also like i don't know i think in jared he just was like uh he just went like Full on,
just a creepy degenerate.
Anyway.
Today's we are going to be playing Mega Bonk.
For those who don't know what Mega Bonk is, it is a basically it's like 3D vampire survivors.
So if you like vampire survivors, you'll like Mega Bonk.
I saw a lot of people playing Mega Bonk the last.
two to three days and people were getting like super addicted to it and playing like like basically how dicting vampire survivors are is people are getting super addicted to this game and a lot i was also watching like you know fps streams you know like uh rivals and i saw or not i'm sorry that's not fps but you know what i mean shooter streams and then like i was watching people play rivals and people were playing mega bonk in between cues too so i was like oh wait that what is this game like usually when people play something in between cues it might be very interesting and i saw like but i also saw a lot of like other streamers playing this individually and stuff and i realized oh this is basically vampire survivors um and it has it got released like i think like last week i think it released around last week and it already has like you know 3k reviews so i was like okay this seems really promising let me try it out and i did like vampire survivors so i was like oh let's try i mean
it's literally just vampire survivors but 3d um so i figured why not um it is roguelike as well and you can be a monkey yeah you can be a fucking monkey so why not any excuse to be a monkey or i guess or fox quick on the feet and unnaturally lucky shoots fireballs that explode on impact gain one percent luck per level sir oofy be slow but his armor's making pretty chunky all right let's i guess we're gonna be be a furry,
I guess.
There's also Mega Chad.
Wow.
Calcium.
Okay, Cloudia.
I don't know.
I don't like that he's slow.
So I'm going to try.
I'm going to try the Fox.
Alright.
Well, I guess we'll be a Fox.
A Green Place.
Alright, tier one.
Oh, I guess these are like different difficulties and stuff.
Bum bum bum bum.
There I am!
Hello, sir.
I'm heading to a furry convention.
Do you know where to go?
Wait, do I have to click on it?
No, okay.
What does the Hawks say?
Alright, sound guy.
Let me know, like, if everything's good.
Alright, here you go.
Golden Tome.
Gold.
I feel like I should focus on gold, right?
Like, all these types of games.
It's my
I feel like I should focus on gold since like I need to buy equipment and stuff anyway right yeah it's like the first time but what if you could move faster like it's my first my first match so usually you want to buy upgrades and stuff like this is not the not run so yeah all right let me blow my nose real quick
Yeah, but it's the first game.
So I feel like gold is most important.
Alright.
Wee.
I mean, I'm not too worried.
It's tier one.
I can literally- Oh my god, I cannot stand here.
I- Oh, there's fall!
Oh, fucking course!
There's fall damage!
Oh, mock!
Oh, that's some music.
Oh, fucking course!
I am a fool.
I am only you at speed.
Well, I wouldn't.
I don't know.
I thought I have really...
I thought Fox's kid have really strong legs.
Alright, let's be fast.
I don't know what is ideal.
Alright.
I just want to be a little faster.
Okay, I'm fucking course.
How do I...
Oh, do I just stand there?
What does this do?
Okay.
Oh, offers you a reward.
Gain.
Oh, so there's a rewards where you have to go.
We want, I don't think, let's...
Oh, this is rare.
We'll get that.
Oh, that's cool.
Like, exploring matters then.
Alright, so exploring matters a lot.
Ha ha, oh my god, they could climb.
Gain, 7.0.
Gain, lifesteal.
Alright, guys, do we get silver gold gain or lifesteal?
Silver is metacurrency Okay, yeah, my kryptonite Fall damage We get silver or lifesteal Two or three Lifesteal Greed Alright, lifesteal Yeah, I think we need, I think we need lifesteal Anyway, because I'm like low HP Yeah, I think this is like Risk of Rain Plus like Vampire Survivor But like,
Risk The one thing I don't like about Risk of Rain Because I played Race to Rain before, like, Race to Rain, too.
Is that you don't see, like, so many stuff happens on my screen.
And also, it doesn't tell you what the items are.
Until you take it.
I hate that.
I hate that I don't know what it does until I take it.
All right.
It's so overwhelming.
Let's see.
Chunkers.
Summon's chunky rocks.
Chunkers?
okay like i it just it it's just too much i get so overwhelmed with stream screen clutter i know it's fun but like i just get so overwhelmed oh my god that's a lot of people that's okay i have life still yeah yeah that is a lot i don't know what why are you guys saying chunkers loyal as as I pick some,
I just pick whatever you guys told me to pick.
You know I'm just doing chat field.
I always do chat field.
Alright.
Open.
Yay!
What do I get?
Increase max HP.
I'll take it.
Anything for HP?
What about this?
Oh my god, I'm broke.
Oh, there is, the ramp does make you go a little faster.
Oh my god, what the fuck are you?
Okay, we're gonna leave this place.
I don't feel safe we're leaving this all right projectiles okay more chunkers or gold gain guys one two or three i'll bring the music down a little bit one two or three look because this is super capitalism now more chunk rock good rock up okay let's let's turn down them rock good me one rock okay let me know uh sound got all right resume let's pay it pay to sometimes maybe win we don't even know we'll win oh my god i'm too broke oh my god what the fuck is this please leave me rock protect rock make me feel safe oh my i realized because we're going in like a baby mode i don't even have like uh oh wait what is this what is stonehedge doing here or not stonehedge the eastern island man Oh.
The Maui Whispers a single word.
Oh, credit card.
Increase luck by plus two.
Okay.
I like that.
Oh my god.
Where did he come from?
I forgot.
We don't have magnets because we just started.
We're like babies.
Okay.
Do I have enough?
I should have enough gold.
Okay.
Gold.
All right.
We have credit card.
This should be good.
Nice.
B.O.
Claw.
Plus, at a cost of... What?
Oh my god, I can't banish it.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
I have life still.
I got an item that gave me extra HP, and now I have an item that takes it away.
Wait, what do we want?
More chunkers or fire staff?
One, two, or three?
Or speed?
More damage is good?
One, two, or three.
Rock?
Okay.
but is it good we need chucker's mail no we're i'm doing i'm doing fire i oh my god guys i can't do rock because it's rock against rock is not effective guys you guys know this we can't just do rock when we're against rock but there's something below me oh my god there's a golden skeleton what does that even mean okay i want to over down here to grab stuff.
There seems to be something below me.
I'm a little scared.
Oh, I'm a little scared.
Oh, my God!
Are they doing...
Guys, I don't think they work for me.
I...
I thought they work for me.
I have a feeling that they're very bad people.
Just a little bit.
Alright, I have money, though.
I didn't realize I was challenged.
I saw a thing and I pressed it.
earn 15% more gold from okay I need that more gold equals more fun more fun time all right it's fine I can walk around I'll just keep walking oh no oh oh no oh okay uh more gold okay more gold more gold equals more fun like they say oh my god it's okay I can I talk to them increase HP We'll get that.
We need regen.
We're not okay right now.
I know I said we're okay, but I lied.
We are absolutely, we are absolutely not okay.
We are absolutely, we are not okay anymore.
We are.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Chunkers.
Chunkers, my boy.
Oh my god, there's a chest.
We are, okay.
Oh my god, it's rare.
Increases damage by per 100%.
percent do i have yes okay i have a lot of damage that's okay i'm so rich too oh there's so many things on me there's so many things oh my god i'm running big damage big damage okay and i got okay agility fast we're so fast now we run get out of here get away from me We're so fast.
We're gonna make it, guys.
We have regen, too.
I don't know how far this fall damage will take me.
I am too scared to fight up.
Oh, my God.
And now there's bees.
Oh, no.
We gotta go to the...
We gotta go.
We gotta hug the right.
We got...
Oh!
Guys, chunk...
I get...
We're committed.
We're committed to chunkers.
Bee.
That's a beast.
Oh, I messed up.
I messed up and I couldn't go back up.
It's fine.
We have here.
We're slowly regaining.
It might be a bit, but we're slowly regaining.
We always bet on rock.
Oh my god, there's HP.
There's HP.
That's good.
Okay, increased luck.
We need it.
We haven't went to a shrine yet to cleanse our luck.
To cleanse our soul.
Alright.
Yay.
More gold.
It won't hurt.
Alright.
We're almost getting back everything.
And we have HP.
I don't even know where we are anymore.
Oh, there's a shrine.
Okay, we got the pot.
For the gold.
Oh my god, he's still there.
It's okay.
That's not fall damage.
Oh my god, I see so many people in front of me.
I could oh rock.
Oh, nice.
We actually need that.
We have ice damage now.
Oh, my God.
There's so many chests.
We're rolling in chests.
Croc.
What the fuck is that?
There's so many.
Oh, evade.
Get evaded, bitch.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
Okay, guys.
Rock or speed?
Rock.
Back to back, guys.
Rock or speed?
One or two?
One or two.
all right okay oh oh nice all right oh gain 9.6 oh my god okay now now we should be okay we have so much life still now this is fine i feel so healthy this is so this is fine oh my god there he is there's the easter islands nice okay beer you need more beer here guys drink responsibly there's 309 i can open it increased damage oh my god more damage too that's so good for us that's so good guys this stone golem has been following me for like 20 years i i don't think he's a good i don't think he's a nice man all right now now now it's no more rock guys one two or three fire staff agility or you need to defeat him one okay only one all right oh there's pot too because i feel like i should kill this guy i don't know i have a feeling that like leaving him alive might be a bad oh my god i almost went to the corner oh my god i did go into the corner i did it almost i did oh my god
goblins goblins got me maybe him skill issue okay that was nice guys i'm a hunt guys i'm top 97 point that's a little how many people played how many people play this game all right plus eight silver that sucks i didn't oh nice we can unlock oh nice okay how do we unlock oh can we buy can Can we buy anything or is it just like,
oh, we can only upgrade in game.
Oh my god, there's gun.
Wait, I want gun.
I, guys, I'm top 200k first try.
I got so many rare items.
So off the drop.
Let's see.
I guess like you can only unlock when you do achievements.
Yeah.
So you don't actually like, all right.
I'll try Sir Oofy.
I'm curious.
Alright, let's try Sir Oofy.
This is fun, though.
I'm already having a...
I think...
Now I know why people think this is fun.
This is like...
Not fun.
This is addicting.
Yeah.
I think I definitely should have got double jump.
This is a little frustrating.
Alright.
Let's grab let's grab this first before like they all come in and swore me All right nice
Damage to the leads or crit chance or a percent size what the fuck where where does it grow?
Where does it grow?
I don't okay, I feel like you're you want to pick size of Because it's a beam.
Hey, guys.
And, ah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Or damage to the elites.
Bigger slash attack.
Okay, if it's a...
Okay.
It better be a fucking bigger slash attack, guys.
Okay, nice.
Throw bones.
All right, let's...
Should we try bone or damage?
Oh, damage to them.
One, two, and three.
We're not going rock again.
We're doing something new.
or three bone or or damage no i am i'm exiling the i'm exiling rocks get bones okay let's try the bones where am i throwing it oh there it is okay we gotta talk to the easter island heads oh nice uh region speed or silver one two or three chat build Vampire is a special attack.
Oh, and I got to see the Undertale stream that Toby did.
Apparently, he has, like, the only copy of that particular game, too.
That's so fucked up.
He's like, look at all these new things you can do in Undertale.
Anyway, the only person that could play is me.
It was like that Carmen episode where he opens his own amusement park.
He's like, look at all this cool stuff.
Anyway, only I get to experience it.
I own the only copy.
Charge 4% faster and get away nice.
That's the shrine shit.
Oh.
Okay.
Plus one projectile count.
Alright.
We do have bones.
Or, I mean, damage is good.
I feel like the damage was really good, though.
Yeah, he was rage baiting so hard.
Three?
Backpack?
Alright, backpack.
Okay.
Oh my god, I have so many bones.
There's Bone Town.
Projectile speed.
Tome, knockback tone.
One, two, or three.
I mean, I do have the bones.
I feel like bones would be good for one or two.
Welcome to the bone zone.
All right, we'll do two.
All right.
Oh, we gotta explore.
I forgot about the exploring part.
Oh, I get two slashes as well.
Wait, that's so OP.
Let's grab all the upgrades.
Oh, it's perfect.
boat that's a rare item deal 30 okay so now i have to i have to jump all right nice regen tom sword one two or three i mean regen seems good i got orpa region sword yeah i'm doing you're doing a ton of damage a skeleton not for it is no i can almost i'll just stay here and farm this because i and buy this real quick quick i mean i can almost afford it it's like 75 coins i just need to kill one more all right nice open all right stop purple but increase evasion oh that's good enough all right let's let's head off now now we explore oh my god there's so many chests in front of me but i can't afford any of this okay wait maybe maybe ufi is good I feel like I'm not getting,
like, as overwhelmed.
More sword, regen, or size?
I'm so many chests, but so little.
Wait, why did he go?
Why are you running?
Hey, get back.
Oh, because you're rich.
That's right, you can't hide your money from me.
That's fucking right.
Wait, what's this?
I remember there was...
We never opened this box yet.
Is he a good box or a bad box?
Okay, it's a nothing box.
We cannot do anything to this.
I guess we're not.
Okay, I need a jump, though.
We're more damage.
Wait, I should have enough money now.
Okay, let's go this way.
Slash, slash, slash, slash.
Slash, slash, slash.
Wait!
Banana!
Oh my god, is this the Fable Monkey?
The Monkey Mode?
Oh my god, I found a hidden banana!
Oh my god!
It's monkey time!
I think I can...
Oh, I can play the monkey now, I'm pretty sure.
Okay, so one of the secret characters is you can be a fucking gorilla.
Got my potassium.
40% chance of poison enemies on hit.
Moody cheese, my beloved.
It's monkey time.
We're all...
Wait, what the fuck is that?
What are you?
Hello, sir.
Shake that bush.
Oh!
Bad bush!
bush guys it's about how is I supposed to know oh my god oh my god this run is already dead before I knew it oh my god oh my god oh and I did fall I didn't know I I thought oh my god I thought it was a good Why does it have a gun?
Why does the push have a gun?
It was standing there.
I thought he was French.
I swear.
I thought he looked like a friend.
I thought he wanted to help me.
Oh no!
He said, save you beat the bush.
I just wanted to beat friends.
Oh my shit!
Oh shit!
Oh the swarm is coming!
Why can't I have nice things?
Oh my god he does so much!
He does so much!
Oh my god, don't challenge!
Don't challenge him!
okay okay here we go that push kills every why do you keep clicking on him then the guy was like yeah that push kills every run and every oh my god i'm so sad i even i have legendary too i'm so sad i'm so sad um we'll grab this oh my god literally um oh Oh my god,
regen, we reach it, we need as much HP as we can get.
We need as much HP as we can get.
Oh my shit, please tell me that's healed.
Oh, this is so bad.
He's gonna shoot me at any moment.
He's gonna shoot me, isn't he?
He's gonna...
I like how so it's like, yeah, he kills my run every time.
Then why do you keep clicking on him?
Why?
If you know he's bad, why do you keep trying to click on it?
I didn't know he's a bad person.
He was just standing there.
I'm dodging bullets right now so hard.
Um, we need regen.
We need regen.
I don't care.
We need this.
We need this so badly.
Okay.
Oh, it's purple.
It's purple.
It's earthful.
Oh, God.
Okay.
guys okay now now now i'm more calm i'm more calm now one two or three what one two or three thorns or regen regen okay all right one two or three but not oh wait actually we should get the size because it's purple i believe in the earth will oh god oh all right one two or three
increase one two or three two extra jumps or one attack speed 1.1 jump what the fuck does that even mean i don't know but i'm jumping i'm jumping as high as i can all right jump higher and further oh my god okay all right we need that actually oh we got hit oh god oh god he's still trying to shoot me he's still trying so i oh my god oh no shit okay wait i can oh my god oh my god oh my god i'm dodging these shots it's like the fucking matrix right now guys i'm oh wait there he is holy Shit,
there he is!
He's right behind me, isn't he?
He's right behind me with my gun, isn't he?
Holy fuck!
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
We're so healthy.
We're still so healthy.
Oh my god, what did I press?
What did I press?
I got greedy!
I saw him press E and I pressed it.
I don't even know.
I don't know what I pressed, guys.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
it's okay everything is fine everything is fine all right sword right sword or banana
stokey sees red button she presses it too okay sorry it's earthful you're right believe in earthful oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god halfway it's halfway remember when it was 10k oh no not the swarm please not the swarm please i'm already going through so much he's he can bleed guys he can bleed oh it's crazy he can actually take damage What I thought?
Oh my god.
Oh, Father, that bitch.
It's okay.
There's a lot of stuff here.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Epic.
We gotta take Epic.
We have to take the Epic.
It's red.
That means it's extra.
All right.
One, two, or three, guys.
Three, Jen, go Bert.
straight
red means go all right I see one okay I'll get red one okay wrench charge for it and get increased oh my god guys I don't I don't need more charging I don't need more charging I just I can't even find a shrine because I'm panicking there's so much so Okay,
there's more chest.
That's good.
Oh my god, that's not good.
I can't afford it.
I'm fucking broke right now.
Banana ram go!
Go banana ram!
Oh my god!
What do you mean?
There's a new boss now that's after me.
Oh!
Music!
Size.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
Oh my god, there's more?
Oh I- Oh, it's a magnet.
Wait, we should get bone, right?
Bone or sword?
Two or three?
Bone.
Okay, bone.
Okay, now we can do another sword.
Okay, now I don't know.
Now I don't know.
Region.
Sword or size?
Two or three.
One, two, or three.
Region.
I don't know.
There was a lot of people on me.
I don't even know.
I was so overwhelmed.
Oh my god.
Red.
It keeps going.
How much did I leave?
It still keeps going.
That is so OP.
One.
Bluff.
Banana.
Oh my god.
I'm still 3-gen.
There you go.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Let's keep going.
Oh my god.
It does.
and stop banana it finally stopped holy fuck oh my god look at the size of my banana i mean it's the angles guys it's it it's has to see angles i'll show it i'm just showing you the perfect angle for the banana pause all right side do we want a bigger banana or reach it You don't fuck it.
Sword or bone?
One, two, or three?
Three?
More bone?
Three.
Okay.
Wait, that's...
We need that, is it?
Alright.
Oh my god, he's still shooting me.
I'll never stop.
He's after me.
Oh!
my god he's never gonna stop he's gonna chase me till the end of time oh i'm so scared oh my god oh my god i'm so high up oh my god he took me over to the other side oh my god now there's fucking blue monsters okay
legendary oh my god bong time it's mega bong time oh my god i got legendary i got legendary i paid a win that's crazy oh my god i can't afford it i'm still broke i don't understand he's still alive oh my god i can kill him i can kill him he pleads he actually pleads oh thank god oh let me have this first get that bush get him oh my god he was dead g that's a g right get out of here with your fucking oh my god oh my god get out of here and your gun that's a g right and all he gave me was he gave me a comment i i spent like i spent so long and all he gave me was a comment that's so fucked up he chased me for 20 years and that's all I got that's right life is so cruel life truly is so cruel
oh no the final swarm I'm so scared okay we'll do this then banana ram for the final swarm all right evasion one two or three i don't know if i have enough time if we get a power-up drop chance one two or three create or even two okay not enough yes i do common uncommon all right projectile is always good okay that's five we'll just absorb all of XP while we're here just go straight we'll go straight all right I heard the bong I heard the bong oh my god wait they're so fast wait they're actually so fast wait a minute wait a minute I thought they were like I thought they were like a little slower but they're not they're not actually they're actually a lot faster than they're a lot closer than they are in the mirror guys In the mirror,
they're locked.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Please.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh!
What the fuck?
Where am I?
Oh my god, where am I?
It's the heartless.
I'm kidding.
The heartless got me.
I'm getting bad at those.
Alright, 142,000 world.
You know, I take this.
Oh, my top six.
Nice.
You know, I take nice.
That's the perfect record for me.
Yeah, I got the pin that out.
That was harassment.
That was actually some bad touch going on.
Also, sound guy.
Has the sound been a lot better now?
So far.
That was a good run.
That was Sir Oofy.
Sir Oofy.
You don't disappoint.
Wait, can I play Bush now?
That run was fucking intense.
That's right.
Look at me, girl.
Oh my, oh my, wait, look.
Wait, what is the dice?
Is dice the meta character?
That's right.
Look at how many people you have.
Oh, wait, that's top 10.
Never mind.
I thought, never mind.
I thought that was like, what the fuck is the dice guy?
The meta?
All leaderboards.
Where am I?
I was gonna be like damn can't believe it took them that many I was like whoa look at me go but I'm just I'm just a little guy it's all in all in it's a gamble meta all right let's see who did I lock I had to buy a sniper right how do I buy a sniper oh my god I have Alright,
at least I have the banana.
Oh, so this is where I spend money.
Oh, there we go.
I got the luck tone.
Ghost.
Forbidden juice.
Oh, fuck.
I already spent all my money.
Fuck.
Oops.
I got too excited.
Wait, I want the ghost.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
We'll get the ghost next time.
Alright, Sir Oofy has not betrayed me.
He's actually pretty good.
I don't think you can... I don't even know how to unlock monkey i think this is monkey i got the banana all right how do i get tier two all right we got adla okay now i can tell what now i can see why this game is addicting that magnet was so clutch okay he actually hit me already all right jump height i feel like what's difficulty.
I don't want it to be harder.
Oh, I have to find... Oh, I didn't find the boss.
I was just traveling around.
Oh, my God.
I could have...
I'm so stupid.
I didn't realize I was not... Guys, we all know.
I just don't read.
I didn't read.
I didn't realize there was a find the boss objective.
Why would I make it harder?
Only game... I'm not.
Okay, this is good, actually.
Um, sword.
What do you say?
Oh my, I can't believe it.
I had, like, an OP build, and I just...
I didn't read.
I...
I didn't find the bots.
I had actual OP build, too.
I'm so sad.
Oh, it's rare.
I'll only always pick a rare one.
A rare one will never disappoint me.
Okay.
Alright.
1, 2, or 3, guys.
HP.
Max HP.
Firestaff or projectile speed?
What does it like with?
I have no idea.
Firestaff.
More projectile.
Okay.
I want to be able to afford.
I should be able to afford this now.
Alright.
Open Sesame.
Nice.
We have regen.
Alright.
How much is it?
The microwave.
Okay, 29.
I can almost afford it.
I'll farm it here.
Wait, magnet.
Okay, we gotta keep that.
We gotta remember that for later.
Evasion.
We'll do more fire staff for now.
And, okay, I can afford it.
What does it do?
Wait, what?
I need more common items.
Is it like...
Oh, is it a replicator?
Hmm.
Is that what it is?
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, we gotta keep that area.
Alright, we gotta find the boss.
But also hope that boss doesn't fucking kill us.
We gotta...
We gotta live.
Wait, do I have regen?
I do, thank God.
Okay.
I got scared that I didn't.
Difficulty increases.
enemy numbers?
No, that's fine.
I don't need to.
Alright.
Damage tome.
Should I do more damage?
Two?
It eats a random item to dupe.
Like, oh!
Okay, so we don't need the microwave yet.
One or two?
Two?
Alright.
Ooh, there's a shrine here.
I can... I can live.
Just stand here.
Slash, slash, slash, slash.
Oh!
is better than red is better than purple right oh my god too right yeah i want to hit two gotta be sure i had i had to be sure that i'm reading that correctly oh my god why is it like why is it in that corner why are you in that corner oh wait yeah we need that duration all right attack gold or knockback Attack,
right?
Cool down?
Alright.
I assume one would be the best.
Okay, we have to explore there.
Look, guys, I'm finally exploring.
I say as I came back, I walked back to where I was.
Get extra gold when taking damage.
What the fuck?
Why would I need that?
I don't think I can die from this.
Yes.
That's right.
Landed.
I will have to figure out where the boss is.
Yeah, I do want to get These guys out of the way.
one, two, or three.
Hmm.
Damage, sword, or cooldown?
Three?
Two or three?
Okay, three.
Alright.
This chat build will not fail me.
I believe.
I'm going all in on a chat build.
Yeah, I actually need money, though.
how can it fail me you'll not disappoint me right guys there's no way all right open yeah legendary what do you get you can eat so much spaghetti with this bad boy also crits have a chance to become oh nice okay we gotta do like oh my god purple okay we need like we need more crit we need more crit so we can do uber crit oh my god nice we got legendary off the bat okay we have to find we have seven minutes to find the big boss where the fuck would he be i don't know i don't know where he'll be this map is ginormous
that's right i've got a giant ass fork now oh fuck i'll do story because we already we upgraded we upgraded the uh the other stuff anyway what the fuck chakamda terrible Oh my god, Chuck Ham, the terrible slowed me down.
Oh my god, he truly is terrible.
Oh my god, he's so bad.
He fucking slowed me.
Oh my god, not the Medica crit when I don't need it.
Oh, nice.
Okay, that's right.
Can't do anything now, Chuck Ham.
That's right.
Ha ha ha.
Get fucking slashy, slashy.
Oh my god, goodbye me.
Oh my god, goodbye.
It's okay.
Chuck this.
That's fucking right.
Okay.
So, one, two, or three?
Two?
Okay.
I need to find...
I need to find a boss.
Where the fuck would he be?
If I was a boss right now, where would I be?
Where would I hide, like, the coward I am?
Oh, not the swarm.
I have five more minutes to find him.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, my God, that's me running into it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
That's rare.
Okay, nice.
Oh, what's that?
Okay, that's just hearts.
Oh, oh, get out of here.
Okay, I didn't go right yet, so I'm gonna go right.
I'll force my way over.
That's right.
Okay, 206.
Okay, that'll be a while.
Isn't it one with a key?
Like, how do I open that?
I don't fucking know.
Oh, oh, oh, come on, please.
Uh...
Alright, more projectile.
Two or three.
I don't think I...
Do I need...
I don't need to jump higher.
I don't think that's gonna help me Two, okay I don't think jumping will help me guys I don't know I think jumping is pretty useless Oh my god They're all over here Oh I still need to find I still need to find the big boss I don't know where he lives
No what is it guys i don't think it will oh my get over here i know you have money get over here that's right yum yummy oh no oh no they're sending in the bees now oh magnet i shouldn't need that okay all right i don't know if i killed enough to use this but i'll take it uh
uncommon all right one two or fire staff because i used the sword or cooldown two or three not the bees or one really more sword and i'll try oh my god get five stuff oh my god they're just they're all just there oh
okay uh oh my god okay now i don't know Sword?
Sword, cool down, or fire staff?
Three?
Alright, we run.
We run.
Oh, shit, but like, what if I just killed them all, though?
Cool down.
Okay, now we run.
Now we run.
Oh my god, where could that boss be?
I swear, I feel like I explored it all.
Saw word, I feel like I explored it all.
Where could this goddamn boss be?
Okay.
Wait, I have just enough.
Legendary?
God damn it.
It's all just...
It's all just fucking...
Uncommon.
Okay, there's the monkey again.
Okay, now I'm lost.
Now all this is...
It's not good.
I only have three minutes left.
I see the monkey again.
There he is again.
But like, where do I go?
Oh.
Go this way.
Where have I not gone yet?
I feel like I explored it all.
Everything, oh.
Oh.
There.
Oh, shit.
It's fine.
uh no i don't think it's that useful there's a magnet over there i haven't gotten there yet okay i see an easter island too all right we have three minutes might as well use it i'm gonna use it i'm gonna use it i don't care cool down uh damage we gotta talk to him five staff to be upon also gain.
Oh, which one would be good?
Coward's Clug?
Maybe when I get hit?
One, yeah?
Alright.
Let's do it.
Maybe the boss is over here.
Cool it out.
So I keep swinging.
Just keep swinging.
Alright, what do I get?
Pick up range.
Oh, crit!
Crit chance!
I'm going to crit build.
Oh, I'm so fast.
Oh, please.
Let me through.
Wait.
That has to be him.
That has to be the boss.
He's wearing a suit.
What the fuck is?
I don't know.
It's blue.
It's uncommon.
Elite Spoken.
We're not.
Oh, wait.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I'm not doing Elite Spoken.
Talk to Shady Mane.
Okay.
You got money.
I've got.
Alright.
Increase damage by 20%.
Oh.
Wait.
I write a beefy ring.
Yeah, I'm buying that.
Alright, guys.
Damage tome.
Sword.
Or 1, 2, or 3.
I feel like we have enough cooldown, right?
Should we do sword or damage?
1?
Alright.
Ooh, fire stuff.
Where the fuck is the boss?
Damage.
Summon the challenge.
I'm trying to find a goddamn boss.
Wait, there's money over there.
Wait, what's that?
Oh, no, I have two minutes.
Oh, my God, I got distracted.
I have two minutes.
I got...
But Stonks!
Oh, my God.
I'm so rich now.
Damage.
Oh, my God.
I'm so rich.
It's Stonks time.
Got more I kill.
Oh my god, but I have one, two minutes.
I can't help it.
I have two minutes, though.
But, uh, sorry.
We need to find the boss.
No, I don't think challenge is the boss.
There's no way.
I don't think so, right?
It's not, right?
Because I don't know.
I don't know.
This is my first time playing.
My greed betrays you.
Oh, we got another one.
Oh, no.
Where is the goddamn boss?
That's not the boss.
Okay, we have one minute.
Power up multiplier.
That should be good.
Okay, we'll go this way.
Maybe the boss is up here.
I'm so high up.
Maybe he wants high ground.
You don't know that.
Maybe that's where the boss...
There's so...
Wait, that's it!
You see the...
No, that's where I was.
Never mind.
Oh my god.
Where is he?
Where do you live?
I just want to kill you.
Is that too much to ask for?
It doesn't matter.
Oh, there is a magnet.
Guys, it doesn't matter.
We have one minute.
We have one minute to find him.
Because I don't think we're gonna find him.
Okay.
Because I have a feeling.
I have a feeling I'm gonna get going by the ghost.
Just a little bit.
It's just a little suspicion.
I...
Oh my god, I got mega...
At least we got mega chat, though.
Let's go.
We got mega chat.
Let's see.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I think I found it.
It's over there.
I'm going to make it.
Oh, my God.
How do I get there?
12 seconds.
Spawn.
Oh, my God.
And the final swarm comes in.
Ah, that sucks.
I'm so unlucky.
Okay.
Oh, no, not the final swarm with the boss fight.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, we gotta kill him.
We gotta kill him before it's too late.
We gotta kill him.
Oh, my God.
Woo!
Okay, I do a lot of damage.
Thank God.
What do I do?
Why will I live?
Oh, he did it!
Yes.
All right, it doesn't matter what we get now.
We fucking did it.
we're so good at this game we're gaming oh yeah we found him it took us 80 years but we did it that's right you can't do nothing now ghost i'm so lucky i killed your boss what you gonna do now your boss is dead all right let's get shield i don't think it's gonna be house full with these guys they're there they're they're gonna fuck me up anyway No,
these guys are 100% gonna fuck me up, my guys.
They're coming, they're coming, they can't be.
Oh, they're coming, they're so fast!
Oh!
Oh my god!
They're so fast!
Oh, don't touch me, please!
Oh!
Oh my god!
I'm going as fast as I can!
Oh!
Oh my god Oh my god Oh my god Oh my god Why did they want a hug If only I had more Jumps guys Silly me If only I had More jumps My hubris Run Donkey Run Gotta go fast to them there was a portal i had a portal what do you mean don't keep them you mean i didn't beat the game
for oh it's until tier two oh thank god okay you guys landed it was tier two i would only get the portal it was tier two thank god thank fucking god i was gonna be like no you can't do this to me all right it's bone time Apparently you do speed builds.
Speed builds over time.
Also gain damage based on speed.
Dick butt kiss.
Thank you.
That's a great name.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
He just wanted to say that he helped us with times are tough and we couldn't ask for a better person to share for it.
Also, nice birthday today.
If it's not too much, of course.
Okay, you can wish me a happy birthday.
Of course, man.
Happy birthday to you.
dear dickbuckus happy birthday to you yeah happy birthday thank you give the akasupa thank you thank you all right throw bones and undead shredder oh radical like tubular bro um but pose off the sickest tricks all right we gotta do apparently he is like speed build it's all about the speed tubular bro i saw someone in the reviews and they were saying how like um they made a pure speed build for calcium and then like um and then it was so fast it crashed the game oh shit i didn't realize i had to keep i thought that was it so like as long all right the speed of my projectile okay i just gotta be like so fast i just gotta keep being fast pure speed build like he just kept chucking bones and was just too fast All right,
a challenge can be too bad I'm just I just gotta go fast All right, do I do flame walker or more bones all speed all the time He asked again go too fast to play it's great and that it's awful
It's great, but also it's it's awful Yeah, I can tell.
Yeah, I'm not surprised.
He's a ghost rider.
All right.
Just need to find more.
Oh, my God.
Look out.
Whoa!
Six.
I'm shredding.
Tony Hawkins.
Skate.
Skate four.
Oh, my God.
Roooo.
this guy is so cool oh shit okay um all right one two or three wicked right want to see me do a kickflip guys it's okay i'm okay with a difficulty because look at this look at this though It might be harder, but like check out check out this shit's this the sick kick lip All right,
crit damage Oh my god, look at me skating on that rock though I'm shredding it Using an interactable summons ghost.
What the fuck?
How do I enter?
Oh my god.
I'm so fast Wait, I found it!
Wait, that was- wait, what if I just go- I'm gonna go kill it right now?
Do you think it's smart if I go kill the boss right now?
What if I- Look at these moves?
Okay, maybe it's not that smart.
Okay, we know where it is now.
We just gotta remember it.
We just gotta remember to get back here.
All right.
One, two, three.
You're too cool for this.
game.
Oh my god, I'm so little HP now.
Three?
Alright.
Sick.
We need more upgrades, though.
We need a lot more upgrades.
Our upgrades are, like, so bad.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm trying to do tricks right now.
Yeah.
I've tried to do some sick dips.
Okay.
So hard being me.
Tubular.
Oh shit.
I'm fucking up.
Guys, it might not have been smart to increase the damage maybe.
I think.
Guys, I think it might have been a little stupid to increase 50% damage.
Difficulty.
Oh, no.
No.
No!
It wasn't so rad in the end.
Oh, quest.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, I can get more money.
Nice.
Okay, I might have fucked up because I increased the difficulty by 20%.
That was on me.
That, that, no, that, that was on me, guys.
That was a little silly of me.
totally wasn't tubular.
Alright, now that I know, Boney Hawk did not make it.
My brother thought I was just too cool for school, guys.
I was just too cool for school.
It's crazy.
Okay, do we do it again?
Okay, wait, movement speed.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, guys.
Oh, that's okay.
I actually wanted the movement speed, even though there's...
Oh, guys, why are we so fast?
Guys, we can do it all over again.
It's random.
Guys, I can't.
I gotta be fast.
It's in my bones.
Guys, it's in my bones.
You can flip.
You don't understand.
Oh, my God.
I can do bone and arrows.
I can be a Minecraft skeleton.
We gotta make the speed build.
Guess if a Minecraft skeleton now, let's go!
We're minecrafting too.
You know a silver game?
We need that.
Oh my god, crit.
Yeah, I'm poor.
Skating doesn't pay.
Who would have thought?
Skating doesn't pay, guys.
I am opening a Kickstarter, a GoFundMe so I can keep doing my Wait, one or two.
I'm opening a GoFundMe for calcium.
So I can continue to live my life as a radical skater.
Bones are all you have.
Okay.
All right, let's grab this.
Beer tab.
Oh my god, I gotta stop.
I gotta actually let...
Oh, nice.
More bone.
Oh, movement speed.
Fuck!
No, we have to.
We have to be fast.
We gotta be fast.
As much as I love purple, we have to be fast.
Oh, wait.
Key!
Wait.
We got fun monkey.
Wait, we have the key.
We can free him.
Gotta go fast.
Guys, we gotta find him.
Where is he?
Oh, this is the greed strat.
I'm greedy.
What made you choose?
Can we skate or tie?
It seems a skater skill.
We chose them both.
It's skate and die.
Oh my god, we gotta find the monkey.
Don't worry.
I'll save you.
Don't worry, monkey.
I'm skating.
I'll be a hero.
Oh wait, shit.
There's a try.
I'll be a hero after this try.
I know.
This is a little bit more important.
Uh, we'll get shot.
shield.
Wait, what's this?
Why is it red?
Boss curse.
Okay, let's not grab that.
That doesn't seem like fun.
Okay, he has XP.
How do you bone?
We got a five.
Bone.
Where the fuck is the...
Where is he?
I'm skating, but I can't see in the five.
him maybe it cursed them i i don't know it doesn't sound oh wait wait crit or power up slash thank you for the super chat thank you thank you welcome to it our bone zone three all right i'm trying to find oh oh that's the shady man okay i don't have money though because i just spent on this chest Oh my god,
there's two shady men.
I'm sorry, there was just a chest in front of me.
I had to spend it.
Oh my god, where the fuck is that monkey?
Alright, nice.
Movement speed.
Oh my god.
Nothing can stop me now.
I'm so fast.
Oh my god, nothing can actually stop me.
Alright.
Wait, precision.
What the fuck is that?
all right oh crit chance oh i didn't read down here okay one two three projectile speed or one crit all right oh movement speed let's go oh my god i'm so down nothing can catch me let's go
okay we can skate through all of this we gotta save the monkey Monkeys save the world!
The one time I can't find the monkey is actually crazy.
But I think...
The monkey is so rare.
Wait, movement speed.
I'm sorry, Bo.
But I have to keep going fast.
Okay, we'll get the Bo.
We have to keep going fast.
I'm grabbing it.
Oh my god, he's coming.
the terrible oh shit oops uh oh my god he can't catch me now i'm too fast for school oh my god wait i'm actually way too fast now is there a thing such as too fast wait wait the guy the dragon was right there is a thing as too fast Oh Wait, Easter Head Alright Oh wait,
I'm always opening chests too Wait, we need that Oh my god, I can be even faster, let's go I Oh shit, oh shit Wait, I'm definitely, oh no, I'm gonna die I'm gonna die because I went too fast Oh no No!
My hubris!
I keep wanting to go!
Oh no!
Where the fuck is the bucket?
Where is it?
Oh no!
I'm still trying to find the bucket!
Oh my god.
find him.
I swear.
What is this?
Oh, attack speed and damage.
Oh my god, where is he?
I'll get the bow.
Oh my god, I'm still trying to find him.
It's been five minutes.
Fuck yeah, I'll challenge.
Surely nothing bad will happen.
I can't believe it.
I have found zero monkeys.
I don't know where he lives.
Oh!
Where does he live?
I keep looping.
I can't help it.
I don't know where I am anymore.
Wait, wait, maybe I can.
Maybe.
Maybe?
Nice.
Oh my god, more.
More.
More movement!
More speed, more!
More!
More speed!
Alright, there you go!
More!
Oh my god, more!
I will go fast for it.
A level eight.
Let's go.
It never stops.
Maybe I'll find the monkey now and how fast I'm going to speed.
I feel like I'm just most likely I'll die from just accidentally hitting.
Oh my god.
Even more.
Where am I?
Guys, I think I'm going a little too, a little too fast.
Okay, let's get the damage real quick.
Sick airtime.
Okay, projectile speed, let's just grab that.
No such thing as too fast.
Oh my god, look at this.
I'm gonna start shredding.
I'm shredding.
I don't think the enemies can catch up to me anymore.
Like, I'm actually just...
I'm taking damage from, like, this guy's air attack.
Oh shit, I spoke too soon!
He landed right in front of me.
Oh my god, oops.
I almost died there.
I actually almost...
Oh, there's the boss.
Nice.
But where's the monkey?
I'm still trying to find the monkey.
Oh, shit.
Oh!
I landed into the ground.
I went too fast.
I kept trying.
I'm trying to find the monkey.
I landed.
Okay.
slap my head oopsie the green but loki's so cool i was so cool though guys i really want to try and get the speed build going i was so cool you don't understand i was so cool
was i was i the coolest My need for speed.
It was pretty cool.
Yes, you were.
Alright.
Oh, I'm so slow now.
I'm not used to it.
I'm not used to how slow I am.
It's so wrong.
I don't know how to...
I don't...
I don't know how to feel.
Alright, increased luck, yeah.
Guys.
It's just so slow.
It doesn't feel...
I can't go back to living like this.
Guys, ever since I started shredding.
Oh, no.
You can't put me back here.
It's no longer cool.
I'm addicted to speed.
I have a problem.
I have a need for speed.
I feel like an ant now.
I'm like a little...
Oh, silver.
I'll do fire stuff.
I'll just have more project...
Oh my god.
Oh god, we can't go down from here.
Let's go this way.
It's just so wrong.
I'm going through withdrawals.
My speed draws.
I was the king of the world.
I had everything.
I had so much.
I was going a thousand miles per hour.
We pick up range.
We more convenient.
Knockback, projectile.
What do you projectile?
I don't think we need knockback.
Oh, I can...
I almost forgot about sliding.
Ooh.
Now I'm actually straining.
I'm so sad.
I had the key, too.
Oh, knockback will keep you alive when you're speed.
Oh my god.
Epic.
We gotta get epic.
I'll get more bones.
Increase that calcium.
Okay.
Poison.
That's good.
All right.
Don't take any damage for two minutes.
Oh, that's good.
I'm raging now.
I'm going through a rage attack.
Oh, now there's the monkey.
Oh, wow.
Okay, thanks.
Now the monkey just shows up.
We get one, two, or three.
I just went, the one time I needed it, it never showed up.
One?
All right, let's do greed a little bit.
That's fine.
It's just a little greed.
Okay, there's the boss now.
Okay, now it's a little easier to find all this.
We're not going to activate the boss yet.
Jump high.
Okay, we're not...
Actually, I don't know because we're shredding.
I...
I don't know.
Shit.
I don't know if like jumping would be good.
But we do luck.
You want to jump?
How high can you jump?
Woohoo!
Ow.
Whoops.
Alright.
Maybe a little too high.
Oh, cooldown is good.
Okay.
Try 40% faster.
God, I just need speed.
I have everything but speed right now.
I literally just need speed.
More speed!
Ow.
God, where are the keys, though?
All I need is double jump now, true.
We are not, okay, we're not talking to without random bush, guys.
Oh, nice, revolver.
I get gunned now.
Okay, where's...
Oh, shit, chuck him.
Oh my god, we were so close to unlocking this too.
Come on.
Nice.
Uh, shield.
What is the power I'm up multiplied?
Increase the power.
Oh!
Okay, let's do knockback.
My Chocom's almost dead, though.
We can get him.
I don't want to deal with all of that bullshit.
Alright.
We got...
or project one two or three guys more bone five step or projectile
projectile all right i'm so sad we need oh my god i'm gonna die nice too cool down that's good where all my speed level up okay poison all right one two or three Chat build chat build
I'm not getting shot at again I'm not I refuse to get shot at Not again That was torture I crave this bee It was so good I want to go back I I wanna go back!
Bring me back to the good old days!
Alright.
We got this now.
Attack speed.
So we can be extra fast.
Bone town.
Red.
We like you when it's red.
Alright.
One, two, or three guys.
I can't get speed no I already fucked it up no I can't be fast no more I can't believe it I fucked up the speed field because I didn't take speed it was one it was only one instruction and I messed it up I the one instruction they gave me was to just take speed and yet somehow I forgot to take speed I can't believe it how could I mess this up okay maybe return it also spawn two extra charge stride for future wait jump high or free okay guys what if I can just okay I need oh man you're damage me me one step plan was just too complicated three you guys i don't know if i i should be guys what okay you're right you're right that's silly me i got an idiot i was like why the did you grab the jump because now because now that i can't go fast i i might as well Just jump high so I can do my sick-ass kickflip.
At least I can do these sick-ass flips, though.
Let's go.
Fly away now.
Fly away.
If I can't go fast, at least I can fly.
So sick.
So true.
Where can I go?
Where is just, like, climbing up here?
That guy, what is the fuck is this?
That's right, get nuked.
Okay, I should have saved it, but whatever.
It is what it is.
I could have saved that.
Bone.
Rare.
What do I get?
Back to it.
And gain it.
Oh, nice.
I got reflect.
That's cool.
pretty sick.
I don't have money for another shady man though.
We need to find...
We gotta find the key again.
I don't know how I get to the key, but we gotta find it.
Okay, wait.
We can try to push, man, because I have a clock here.
I'm not driving the difficulty.
Oh, I have two clocks.
All right.
One, two, or three.
so gnarly bony hawks pro skater
all right let's go grab this i don't know where i left him though to be fair i have no idea where i left uh where i left the bush man he could be anywhere right now
armor one two or three guys Look, elite, uh, or armor.
He's just in out.
Yes, I know he's.
Guys, I know he's in the bush, but guys, I'm surrounded by bushes.
Which bush, though?
Which bush could it be?
New thorns.
Thorns might be nice.
It could be anywhere.
he's great oh my god he's like stood in front of me oh my god bone that's bone zone okay where's the shady man I think I have enough money now I'm so sad I have so much money but yet no oh nice magnet that's fine uh one two or three like three bushes it's just three bushes ago when did it become three bushes ago do more thorns because it's urfla oh bone always pick cool down uh oh no now i don't know
Bone.
It's always bone talent.
Oh, wait.
There's a microwave.
Oh, there's a shady guy.
There's another shady guy.
Okay, Ice Cube.
I need 603.
Okay, I just gotta save up money.
Oh, my God.
Where is...
Where the fuck is he?
Okay, we need 603.
100 gold.
Uh.
Trying to cool down.
I feel like we don't need more bone yet.
I'm trying to find the shady.
I'm trying to find a bushman.
Wait, is that?
That's green.
That's green equals bone.
That's green equals...
No.
Fuck.
Where is he?
Okay, these are all...
Okay, it has to be marked with a green, right?
Wait, I didn't talk to him yet.
We're not jumping higher.
Nice.
Guys, we're not jumping higher.
We jumped high enough.
Guys, we don't need a jump higher.
Nice.
Oh, I got 700.
Move my speed.
Yes.
Okay.
I have ice cube now.
Weepo.
We could go higher, Joki.
Guys, we don't need to go higher.
I could kill him really fast.
Okay.
Nice.
I guess we're not saving the monkey today.
I guess we're not saving him today, guys.
Unless I can find...
Oh, wait, there's a nuke here.
Okay.
Wait, that's really good.
Unless I can find him.
I don't think we're saving him.
more air time I wonder the nuke works on the boss Let's find out Alright let's do it I'm gonna try There's a I'm gonna try I'm gonna try nuking the boss Let's see Boom Okay we found Alright guys the nuke for some reason He can survive He survives a nuclear bomb Ha ha ha That's like crazy.
Holy shit.
Bone.
I was not expecting that.
I honestly, I thought I could just nuke him.
Yes.
It just felt right, but it's okay.
I saved the clock for this.
Guys, I think I'm winning.
Oh, shit!
It's a camp.
It's a camp made it.
Nice.
Alright.
I like how it gave me, like, a...
A common.
Even though I literally killed the boss.
You know what?
It's too fast, Steph, because I feel like we have...
Oh, my God!
Quality time!
Alright.
Alright, before we do...
I want... Oh, okay, let's take the portal.
Goodbye, everybody.
Goodbye.
I'm not going through that.
Where am I?
Hello.
The deep portal.
The vibes are off.
Oh, this is a new area.
We can't save him.
He'll be stuck caged for his crimes.
We don't know if he's an evil monkey.
Not everyone can be Harambe.
All right, power up, drop chance.
Two or three?
But the monkey.
Three, okay.
Guys, not all gorillas are Harambe.
It could be an evil gorilla.
he was caged for his crimes for a reason oh my god turbo shocks oh my god now i can actually go fast oh my god there's a key all right we're gonna free harambe i was wrong we're gonna free harambe guys okay uh damage how did you how would you know that
Double 30 has calcium.
Movement speed.
This is the only time I can get movement speed.
At least we can break.
We gotta get this.
I'm not increasing the difficulty.
I think this is hard enough right now.
Hello, brothers.
That's right.
You didn't believe in me.
must die.
You didn't believe.
Oh, wait.
Pick up range.
God damn it.
Okay, we're going to do pickup.
I know how much I would love to jump higher, guys.
Two or one, two, or three.
Jump!
Damn it.
My brothers didn't believe in my dream.
I had a dream, brothers.
But you abandoned me.
That's right.
He was a skater boy.
She said, see you later, boy.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
Next shit.
Oh, movement speed.
Oh, my God, we're doing it.
We're bringing back the speed build.
Oh my god.
It's just like old times.
Okay, nice.
We found the boss here.
Okay, now we just...
Now we just need to find...
We need to find Harambe.
And it all would be good in this world.
It's just that easy.
We gotta find Harambe, guys.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
We just gotta unlock this.
One, two, or three.
Chat build.
I'm so...
fast.
I'm speed again.
Rambi the way.
We gotta resurrect Rambi.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, he's 53k HP?
Okay, this is gonna take a while.
I just realized he's 53k HP.
This will take a while, guys.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright.
It's okay.
We can jump so high until
Attack speed I don't know what the boss curse does And I'm too scared to find out I'm way too scared to find out what he does We did all of that already Music time
Okay Oh Oh Oh, Magnet.
I did my kick jump.
My kick flip.
All right, the swarm is incoming, but it's okay.
I can do this.
Whoa!
I can jump over.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's fine.
I still jumped over them, technically.
Let's go down.
Let me feed.
Oh!
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, my God.
This is so bad.
Guys, what?
I invested.
Oh my god, there's Harambe.
Harambe, the wait.
I'm coming for you.
I'm bringing you back.
Let's go!
Find and release him.
Oh my god, he's doing it.
He's doing the kickflips.
Let's go, Harambe!
He's kicked the feet.
Do it up.
He's back.
And thus, we return Harambe.
Oh, my god.
We did it.
I don't know how.
Just bone.
Oh, shit.
Why do I don't need a credit card?
Please, I need something else.
Oh, my god.
We need to nuke.
We actually need to nuke everything.
It's too much.
Okay.
love i i don't know how i lived but i lived bitch that was very scary that was very very scary
okay i'm gonna find more shrines all right there's chests here i'm gonna grab the chest i have so much money right now nice speed it's always good to have speed okay a thousand Okay, I don't have money anymore.
Okay, there is something over there.
What is that?
Experience?
Did I kill him for the XP?
Come on, come on.
How are you still alive?
Oh, quantity.
It's legendary.
Oh my god, he's still here.
I feel like I have to kill the big boss before I do anything.
Oh my god, please.
Where are the other shrines?
I'm unstoppable now.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Nice.
Okay, regen.
Regen is always good.
Oh, there's the Easter Head.
Max HP, yes.
Oh, my God.
All right, let's do a little more damage to the 50k golem.
That's just a little...
Whoa!
That's okay.
We did a little bit more damage at least.
Thank God.
Is this.
Oh, I got a little shield.
Oh my god.
I know there's another magnet somewhere.
I think if I get another magnet, it would actually be so good.
He was a skater boy.
She said, see you later boy.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
That's too much.
It was too much.
Too much skating.
Too much.
ski all right i did not expect to have so many goblins show up let's get bone clear guys clearly i should have invested in more in more bones that was my bad if only i had more bones chat if only if i could if only i jumped more oh my god i was a fool why didn't i jump invested more in jump guys i was so foolish nice it's monkey time okay but we can also unlock a gun i'm gonna lock the gun just in case what other stuff can i unlock what's demonic soul i needed that height oh my god i have clank oh that's gun all right but first monkey Those bananas that return to the owner Climb up walls Oh my god,
I can climb up walls No one knows where he got the shades No one asks He's just too cool for school Alright I'm ready for my DK rap Oh my god, he's so slow I don't want to attack him Oh, there he is He's so slow Okay, one, two, or three Returns a monkey No one cared until I put them on It's not ever since I went Ever since Ever since I started skating I can never I cannot go I just want to go back I Oh,
I'm so...
Oh my god, wait, how do I jump?
Me, monkey.
Ooh, ah, ah.
Monkey,
go.
Monkey see, monkey do.
Alright.
Oh, nice.
He has no stallion.
This card has a fun...
Oh, wait, standing still.
Oh, wait, nice.
Okay, but when will I ever have?
That's a little useless, but okay.
Oh!
Whoa!
Okay, I'm...
Okay, that heals.
Whoa!
That heals a lot.
Wait, I climb.
Monkey climb.
Uh, what do we want?
What would be good with monkey build?
The last member of the DK crew.
That's a lot of region, yeah.
Banana?
Or speed?
Speed?
Okay.
I climb.
Nice!
Rare!
Increase damage.
Okay.
So I have one damage increase.
That's enough.
Monkey C, Monkey Dune.
Monkey open chest.
Monkey broke.
Monkey poor.
Monkey sad.
Oh yeah, I can.
Just enjoying the little campfire.
White dead.
Monkey sad.
Must find white.
Oh my god, we're so fast.
Well, actually, speed might actually be a fucking Dutch build.
Alright, increased damage.
Regret.
Alright, there is...
Nice, alright.
There's a lot of strides here, which is good.
I don't really know exactly what build to do.
Oh, projectile speed would be so good.
No, that would be.
We gotta grab him.
We gotta kill him for XP.
Alright.
One, two, oh, lightning staff.
Oh my god, I got to smite people.
Monkey, god.
Yo, is that a robbit?
Love money.
No more money.
Regret.
Alright.
Monkey, now god.
De-smite.
Alright.
Projectalia.
We can...
Plung more...
More bananas.
More bananas in my banana world.
Do I climb this?
Will I get...
Ball damage?
Oh my god, look at this.
Oh my god, tapstree!
Monkey movement.
I need to fuck it.
Let's do it.
I'm a strong, independent gorilla.
1, 2, or 3.
Monkey Paracord.
Hey, how did you get Donkey Kong?
How did you buy Donkey Kong into this?
2?
1 or 2?
I see 1 and 2.
one all right i guess i could like be like stronger i feel like the ghost is so useless honestly all right we've there's a okay we're gonna save the magnet for later i don't think we actually need the magnet yet
uh clap your cheeks so hard it generates hot guys we're gonna start guys monkey gonna clap some cheeks guys
Monkey freak That's right, line up Haram is ready Haram is ready Oh shit Crit Oh, I did not mean to Okay, it's fine He's like, not He's like so Okay, here's the shading Oh, fuck, okay, it's fine I'm gonna kill him first then all right one two or three banana actually banana agility a freaky freaky god we're gonna clap the golem's cheeks guys three all right it's almost dead nice he's dead oh my god why did you have to die on top of a goddamn rock god it's always like so useless though oh wait what's silver Oh,
silver.
I don't think we need silver.
Wait, attack speed for the banana?
Or regen?
Oh, that's so hard.
Okay.
I feel like attack speed would be so good for banana.
Then regens are also really good, too.
One?
Alright.
We'll do.
I'm just, like, thinking.
Oh, man.
I feel it.
Regens also.
Wait, I up on hit.
Clapped her cheeks.
Nice.
Now we're better at clapping cheeks.
Oh, okay.
It's upgrade lightning.
We don't have a lot of lightning upgrades anyway.
Alright, I think now we can use this.
Banana.
Lightning.
Because it's red.
It's red good.
Okay.
Alright, now what?
We do lightning because it's blue?
I don't have money for the shady man.
Okay.
Increase the banana size!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Two
Alright, let's see Where do we go?
Oh, there's something up top Monkey claw Oh, oh, oh Nice, another shady man Too bad I'm broke Swarm is coming Okay, I have my trusty banana around the cat oh fuck okay these are all really good upgrades uh one two or three they're all rare chat stop shaming bigger banana mean better more banana one one okay cool down think cool down means more banana time.
One, two, or three.
More attack.
More monkey.
Three?
Three.
Okay.
That ain't stuff.
Oh shit.
I don't even think I can...
Oh!
No way!
Monkey climb!
Not bad day for a monkey when monkey can climb.
Oh, that is so strong.
I did a great chance.
That is so strong why I just stand there and heal.
That's crazy.
I just stood there.
Okay, I should...
I have enough for the shady man now.
I need to get to...
Do this challenge too.
Because I feel like the challenge isn't that bad.
Okay, purple.
Oh, that's hard.
Life steal is really good.
He just stood there to mix more ins.
Then I can have more projectile.
Life steal, right?
Life steal or projectile?
Life steal?
Oh, wait.
This guy's money.
Oh, double life steal.
Okay, we got to find the shady man now.
Do we have enough money?
Oh my god, that's so many I killed there.
He's fine.
Don't worry too much.
I still...
Only it's just I haven't found a boss yet, so I'm a little worried.
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He can't read, he can't spell, but you cross this con, he'll send you to hell.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Alright.
It's my time.
Oh, there you go.
There's Shady Man.
A little Shady Man.
Do I... I don't think I can... Do I open up chests for this?
I don't know.
I feel like I don't, though.
You say it's worth... I mean...
Okay, I'll open more.
There's a chest behind me.
There's literally a chest behind me.
Okay, nice.
Clap time.
I like how majority of my upgrades is literally...
clapping cheeks.
Oh my god, what is Harambe doing?
Holy shit.
Harambe.
What are you doing, buddy?
Alright, that's a lot of money.
That's really it.
Another one more movement speed.
We like that.
We like that movement.
And there's more shady guys here.
movement speed.
What is transfusion?
Does anyone know?
Is that life steal?
It dicks up for a robbit.
Do it, right?
Okay.
That sounds like life steal.
I'm not too sure.
I have a lot of money now.
Okay, nice projectile.
Oh, we need this actually.
I feel like we've farmed a lot in general.
We're having not gone.
Maybe the right side?
Yeah, the right side looks like I haven't walked over here yet.
Oh yeah, I know there's a lot of stuff around here.
Alright, beer.
Beer-O-Cla.
Oh my god, there's so many shrines here.
Alright, that's good.
I'm staying in the middle here.
Uh...
Do we need armor?
Armor or pickup range?
Two or three?
Beer-O-Cla.
Pick up?
We're not doing one.
I don't think that's useful.
Armor, okay.
Uh, oh, fuck.
One or two.
I am a, I am projectile.
I have my banana rang.
One or two.
Crit damage or projectile.
One, okay.
I feel like I do have...
This is a projectile build.
Okay.
All right, I'm standing in the middle.
Look at that.
I'm gaming now.
But we still have yet to...
The only issue is...
The only issue right now is that we have yet to find the boss.
Or more banana.
Three?
All right.
Oh, crit damage.
Crit damage is always good.
We're doing so well, except we have yet to find the boss.
Oh, I found it.
Never mind.
Ask and ye shall receive You know what, okay, let's call these guys too I ain't afraid of you That's right I found the Oh, oh, ah Harambe not scared Harambe strong
I just, Harambe stand still Okay, maybe Haram don't stand still.
Okay, Harambe don't stand still.
Harambe decided standing still might be bad at you.
I am the one who claps.
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
Airtime!
Okay, luck.
I might not be the skater boy anymore, but I'm still a skater boy at heart.
Okay, I know I killed a lot, so I'm going to activate this Lightning Oh, cool legendary Oh, fuck, okay One, two, or three Winter jump One,
two, or three
Banana Banana Banana lightning all right oh shit there's so much blue what's still going I don't know I don't know anymore one two or three there's so much monkey become Winston cut four lightning okay oh my god it's still banana I was like it's still going oh my God,
is he back?
Where the fuck is Chuckum the Terrible?
Oh, there he is.
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
He's getting destroyed.
That's fucking right.
Need to make sure.
I knew I, like, left a lot, too.
I was like, there's so much I left around.
Nice.
Red.
I don't even have to read it.
I look at the color and I'm like, that seems like a lot.
I don't even read what it does.
I was just like Red equals strong
Increase HP Regen The regen Regen's always good Holy shit I'm so I'm bawling Right now
Okay There's I'm not gonna take that Okay we gotta go to the boss now I am not fighting the ghost The ghosts are so annoying oh i don't know how i'm doing these jokes but i'm gaming
okay let's grab this real quick it's okay i'm grabbing this so we can get rich this is my get rich quick scheme oh my god he's almost dead already how is he almost dead
all right we did it yeah boss i think it's all the chest i actually opened so many chests guys i i open so many chests okay we still have okay we gotta go to a portal one two or three lightning yeah no he definitely got clapped 100 got clapped all right go through i'm not i'm not dealing with the final score me through let me through let me in i can't it's too late i'm too scared i have trauma from the ghost ghost too scary
too much trauma one or two
baby so cool
all right
I got this
Alright Projectile More banana
More banana Means more death Okay there's a magnet here I wish I could like mark the mini map And be like Oh remember to come back here Alright sit down Gonna do my smores real quick Alright just for you I should I feel like I, alright, common sense wise,
I should do damage, but what if I can jump a little bit more?
Next time, I swear, guys, next time I'll get the jump, I swear, I swear, I swear, next time, next time, I'll do it, guys, next time, I'll do it, guys, next time, like, don't you, you know, there is never a next time, is there?
Next time, guys.
Next time, I swear.
Dealing as my bananas can explode now.
Holy shit.
There's so much bananas.
I need to be with my brother.
That's okay.
I'm just having a little picnic too.
Attack speed.
Now it's fast banana.
Gotta go.
Go fast.
Holy shit, where am I keeping all these bananas?
Not in my pants, that's for sure.
Oh my god.
Is that your banana?
Are you just happy to see me?
Wait, there's a shrine here.
Holy shit, this is a tanky.
Bob, let me know.
uh more banana you can never go wrong good lord you can never go wrong with more banana guys all right there's a magnet here oh shit knocked him again it's all right i'm like super strong now i can literally just i cannot stand there i would love to be able to stand there okay
that's oh nice i got it okay nice that was really close he stepped on me once and like i lost half hp so like that was very risky all right nice see i told you look now now i could i told you guys I told you there will be a next time.
You didn't believe me.
I didn't lie.
Look at that.
Now I can jump.
Oh my god.
Big banana.
Yes.
Alright.
Nice.
Swarm.
Oh my god.
Even bigger banana.
when when will the banana stop it'll never stop there's this a banana free world oh it's gonna be a sec it might stop here it's gonna stop here it's gonna stop here i run monkey run okay we gotta grab this holy shit holy Shit.
It might not be a good idea to stand here.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Fuck.
No, this is...
Guys, I'm sorry.
I know you want more, but...
I know you want more jump, but I'm sorry.
We have to think a little more.
Next time.
Just do it.
But you could have just jumped away, Doki.
okay oh my god i keep accident when i climb it like kills me away okay we need to find the magnet i'll get the armor i'm gonna try and find them i left so many magnets i just need to figure out where i left them that magnet here oh nice there it is okay it's upgrade time oh yeah it's upgrade
uh one two or three chat monkey needs to learn fly
monkey deserve oh my god banana banana okay now i don't know cooldown i feel like my cooldowns are i feel like i'm i i feel like i'm throwing them non-stop to be fair lightning snap yeah i was gonna say i feel like i I haven't stopped throwing my bananas to have a cooldown reduction.
I don't think we need it anymore.
I'll go to the boss fight at 3 minutes.
Because I don't know how long it's going to take me to fight.
Ah, fuck.
It sucked.
Okay.
It'll take a while.
I'll just set up a campfire.
Checked out.
More.
There's never...
There's no such thing as not enough banana.
We're gonna have like a We're gonna have a banana shortage after I'm done here Alright Let's go this way I get it Did I explored everything?
Oh no, shady man Uh Oh, yes More I demand more Endless It will never stop Wait, there's something above me Like that, wait, no Is it above me or is it below me?
At no way it's below me.
Okay, wait, okay, let's hope I...
Okay, okay, that's good.
I was gonna say let's hope I don't die for fall damage.
That's like...
That's a little scary.
It's magnet.
We'll do the magnet.
Come to me.
Come to me!
Give me all the agility in the world!
I've worn it all.
Ghost.
I feel like the ghost is useless, though.
Seems like such a useless ability.
Wait, there's something here.
Shady Mad.
Let's do that.
I still don't know what that is, but let's do it.
It seems funny.
His swarm incoming.
Okay, we got to set up the boss now.
It's not...
Actually, I don't know.
think that's smart but that means we're getting oh wait nice okay there's stuff here i can stand here i can't stand here i can't stand oh shit please don't give me too much ball damage please oh my god oh my god it's okay it's okay everything is fine that nuke all right we have to
Okay.
With that boss spawning, I could do this too.
I must have killed a lot.
Oh my god, lightning.
Cool down.
Oh my god!
Did it say like...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, I don't know.
I...
Guys, I'm a little worried.
I know there's a... Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I'm a little worried now.
I'm actually a little worried.
I didn't realize...
Oh, my God!
And Chuck them the tarot!
Oh, we are so fucked!
We are so fucked!
I should have...
I should have invested more time.
Okay, wait.
Wait, wait.
We have the...
Alright.
Okay, where is he?
Where is the boss?
Wait, where is he?
Wait, where is he okay we are doing this and then we are gonna find him oh my god he's right behind me where did he go oh my god he spawned there this fucker this actual fucker why did you spawn behind me oh my god and i have to kill him too oh this is so bad this is so bad i this is so bad this is so bad excuse me i didn't realize he's 500 khp okay i don't know what am i gonna do with all this money but here i go
all right oh my god too that's good that's good i'm always in the air so good okay oh my he's almost oh wait he's not he's not jk i'm always in the air
That's right, I have double jump, bitch.
Whoa!
Full banana.
Always go full banana.
That is the key.
Oh my god, just banana.
Just banana all the time.
All the time.
All day long.
Oh god, oh no, it's the ghost.
Oh, where's that portal?
Oh, there's no portal.
Thank God.
There's no portal.
It's just we just gotta survive now It's just survival
Okay, we did it
Projectile speed It's just living Mission survive There has to be a lot.
I did not stop Oh, there's so many the oh the black coaster coming soon.
Let's just jump.
Let's jump away.
Jump our worries away.
The extra fast coaster coming.
Oh, I'm so scared.
You're so fast.
I'll grab this.
Cool down.
I don't even know if I need the cool down.
I can't even see my monkey anymore okay keep going and we water the way water water then we oh no oh no they're coming oh they're coming the really fast ghosts are coming oh oh they're here they're here oh my god they're so fast oh my god i have airtime It's okay.
I have it every time.
You can't catch me on the gingerbread mat.
Oh, they're catching me.
They're catching me.
Yes!
Oh, I'm climbing.
I'm climbing.
How is this normal?
Oh, my God.
No.
Oh, oh, I'm flying.
I'm flying.
It was so banana.
Trust in the banana, don't you?
I don't know!
It is everywhere!
Don't stop, Charlie.
You touched the floor and you're dead.
We did two, two, almost two minutes.
You didn't believe in Harave enough.
Yay, top 43.
You know, I'm making really good progress for my first time playing.
Should have invested more in jump, Doki.
The key is to never touch the floor or you die.
All right, who do you want to play?
Do you want to try?
Clank?
Do we want to be a clanker or gender-bend Robin Hood?
Oh, Clank has a gun?
Wait, but Robin Hood has more experience.
Okay, we'll try.
We'll try Clanker or Clank.
Orra.
Wait, I want Orra, actually.
I'll grab Orra.
And now we're...
Wait, we can have more quests, though.
Where is it?
There we go.
Poison.
A couple of them.
I got a gun.
Now it's over.
It's over.
This is the gun I used to kill.
Arambe the White.
Nice.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, I got another one.
Mega Chad.
Oh, because I got aura.
Wait, I want to unlock Mega Chad.
Alright, we'll do a clanker first.
Uh...
I'll create another weapon.
Yeah, Turbo Skates.
Ooh, that would have been good for...
That should have been good for calcium.
Alright.
tank type fire multiple bullets at enemies being 1 okay guys this is actually this is so addictive it is literally vampire survivors i would say this is more fun that more fun than vampire survivors because it's not 2d like you can like go everywhere i was this is definitely this is more fun than vampire survivors
because i i can jump i Yeah, the movement is really fun.
Yeah, I really like the movement.
I didn't see it.
Yeah, the movement is so...
Alright, I'm ready for tier 3.
Alright.
And I haven't even locked everything in.
Pew, pew, pew.
That's right.
I got a gun now.
It's high news somewhere in this world.
Wait, this guy's me!
That's right.
What you gonna do?
Like, let's get...
I don't even know what... And this is me not knowing any of... Okay, let's get the boss curse.
I'm curious.
What does this do?
What is he doing?
What did it do?
Wait, guys, what does the... I don't know what I did.
No!
Wait, what did I do?
Wait, why is it doomed?
Why...
What happened?
oh plus one boss oh but do i oh wait it's okay i just gotta be really strong guys just believe i just i can be strong as long as i'm super strong it'll be fine right right guys wait i have so little hp oh my god i have so little hp okay i would assume projectile speed or crit What's better?
Surely, right?
One or two?
Create order one?
Okay.
All right.
Can I regen shield, though?
I assume I- I hope I can.
That would be- yeah, I can't.
All right, that's good.
I just don't have a lot of HP, which is bad.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Oh, shit.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
more does that mean i shoot 10 times i don't even know i just assume i shot more i don't or do i shoot six i do a full crit build for this guy all right that's fine i can do it i just gotta keep shooting i'm the rude intuitive sharpest sharp shooter in the west Yeah.
Alright, it's fine.
I just threw a little shimmy.
Oh, life steal.
Life steal with gun?
That sounds strong.
Alright.
Gun!
Okay, love.
Okay, I don't know if I want to make this hard.
I think I've already done enough.
You need your last...
That's right.
It's a clanker world up there.
Alright.
I need to find a magnet fast.
I feel so slow.
I was jumping everywhere.
I feel so fucking slow.
Oh my god.
I don't...
Oh this is so bad.
Oh how bad is it?
Okay it's not that bad.
The fall damage is not that bad.
Okay that's good.
Oh my god.
joke it's okay all right sword hi sword okay which one one two or three bone sword or toe
bone bone time all right we're back to back to the bone town we're in the bone zone again
oh nice there's a magnet okay we meet that actually oh oh okay now i know i it now i get what the revolver is i i understand i need speed i need speed i need speed i understand now okay one two or three quant oh quantity should i do quantity for the for the projectile or the cooldown i don't think we need evasion too okay i understand i understand i think i might have I think I might have fucked up.
That's okay, I have bone.
I still have bone.
It's okay, it still works.
All I have to do is just use bone.
Oh my god, oh my god.
I'm trying to look behind me, but there's so many things in front of me too.
Okay.
There's a chest when I'm coming back.
This might be a little foolish.
But I gotta grab this.
Nice.
I got one of them.
Okay.
Oh my god, he's stuck.
Oh, he's not stuck anymore.
I spoke too soon.
It's not stuck.
He's okay.
He's a-okay, guys.
Okay, nice.
I'll grab that because it's purple.
No, not- I won't use the magnet yet.
I'm gonna save it.
Okay, I'm a little faster, which is nice.
form is incoming.
But, like, I have gun.
What's the worst that could happen?
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Yeah, what's the worst that could happen, guys?
I have gun.
Woo!
I still have gun.
Oh my god, there's no, like, rare or legendaries.
I feel like I'm not getting any.
Okay, there's a magnet here.
I'm gonna save that magnet for emergency.
Oh my god, this might be an emergency now.
Guys, I think we're at the emergency era now.
Okay.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Gun.
Crit or a projectile count?
Because we are in a crit build.
Gun always wins.
Two?
Three?
Three.
Okay, I see more threes.
Okay, check it out.
God, I haven't found, like...
I haven't found the boss yet, which is bad.
This is fine.
This is still fine.
Oh my god, how much stuff do I have to get?
Alright, we'll do the magnet now.
Oh, bone.
Just because we haven't done any...
Revolver.
Quantity.
Bone.
Revolver.
Uh, now I don't know!
Now I know!
Do we want quantity, agility, or gun?
One?
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
Okay, now we super fast.
Now we can kill everything.
Oh my god.
Wait, that's instant.
Wait, I'm so strong now.
I swear to God, it's all just magnets.
I haven't found, like, any useful equipment.
Useful greens, except for magnets.
Okay, nice.
I gotta break more of the containers.
We never leave the bone zone.
Guys, we're here forever.
We're always boning in that zone.
You'll never leave.
One, two, or three?
One?
Two?
One, okay.
What is that?
Can you see that?
It's like...
Oh, it's the greed thing.
Okay, we don't need the greed.
We can stay here for a little bit.
I feel like HP regen would be good because I have so little HP.
I'm going to do it.
I'm trusting my gut.
Just because of how weak I am.
Just because I feel like I don't have a lot of HP.
So the regen would, like, come in clutch.
Okay, let's grab this chest.
Alright, here we go.
Andrew, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Who's dingy bird?
What?
Wait, who's that?
Andrew, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
What?
I don't know if you're serious or not, but thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What, free?
No, my, oh, gee.
It is a real person?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, here you go.
Okay, knock back.
Oh.
Fuck.
Ah, I feel like so are you.
game would be so good if i just don't like this run three okay let's try i'll risk it uh okay we'll nuke oh i found the boss nice oh my god there he is i i can't i we're not we're not gonna oh we're not gonna don't shake the bush do not shake the bush we've learned do not shake out bush guys we've learned we have we have overcome our mistakes I don't want to start it yet I want to farm a little bit I don't want to start it um I want to get rid of the oh fuck bone I want to get rid of the the mobs first before I go down all right there you go oh my god I forgot I forgot okay this Okay,
this is a little awkward.
I forgot we summoned two.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, nice.
Hey, look, high ground.
He gave me high ground.
Thank God.
That's so nice of him.
Oh, my God.
Oh, this was...
There's four.
Oh, my God.
Say your prayers.
Let me say your prayers.
I may or may not have fucked up guys I may not have made that Oh my god Guys there's four of them
Guys what if I summon six What if okay what if but guys what if there was actually six bosses Oh this is not good This is absolutely not I need speed I need speed!
I need speed so bad!
Oh!
Okay.
That's fine.
Project out.
Okay.
We're just gonna be a bit fast though.
We need this.
We need to outrun all.
We need to outrun this so badly.
Oh, I like shit.
Oh!
Oh my god, there's the shady man.
There's the shady man.
Okay, revolver.
Maybe I can...
Maybe I can stand here.
Nope, I can't.
I can't.
It's okay.
Uh...
Yo, 30...
Three more damage.
Yeah, we'll get that.
Fuck it.
We'll get that.
We'll get that too.
Oh my god, jump higher.
That's what I needed.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we have to kill these guys.
Please.
We have to kill them.
Oh my god, the ghosts are coming.
The ghosts are coming.
We need to kill them before it's too late.
Oh my god, where's the portal?
Where's the portal?
We gotta go, we gotta go.
We gotta go.
We gotta go!
We gotta leave.
All right, nice.
Okay, I can.
I will do a little bit.
We'll farm a little bit before we go to hell.
Well, we'll farm just a little bit.
Oh my god.
I forgot about the boss loot.
Fuck.
Okay.
I forgot all about the boss move.
I forgot all about it.
Can I still make it?
Oh my God, it's fine.
It's fine.
We can still make it.
Oh my God, that's so risky.
This was so risky.
Okay, okay, we go, we go, we go.
We run, we run, we run, we run, we run, we run.
We run, we run, we run.
Oh my God, where is that point?
Oh my God, it's okay.
Run!
Okay.
We made it.
Holy shit.
All right.
That knocked...
When I got the agility shit, I actually came in clutch.
I think I could have died.
Definitely almost died there.
I need projectile speed.
No, I definitely need projectile speed.
Uh, or I can get, or, okay, I do have two.
I am, I, wait, are the bosses elites?
Because the thing is, I do need, I might need, I might need this because I have two bosses, or I could, guys, I could have four.
be so funny if i had four bosses no you don't do don't listen to you don't listen to your your inner thoughts don't you don't give in
cast blood magic damaging oh my god wait that's so good that's actually so good don't listen to intrusive thoughts Don't do it.
It would be very funny, though.
I know it would be so funny.
Pick up Ranger extra jumps.
Shit.
I don't know.
I never knew my time.
Oh, she was your right.
It's double jump time.
It has never failed me.
You're so right, chat.
never failed me oh my god crit damage that is so good actually we're gonna save the magnet we have to save it holy the b hit me one time and almost took off my entire shield
uh i'm gonna get hp fuck it oh i should have saved fuck i should have saved my time okay we'll grab this all right okay now that no okay we have to find the boss quick i think not bad but we we have to find the boss quick because i need to fight so many
wait oh wait there's the xp oh no wait does he disappear no oh what oh my god oh my god He took so much of my HP.
I literally looked away for one second.
Oh, that sucks.
That is not good.
Oh, no.
Oh, oh, the thing resets us.
Oh, thank God.
It resets us up.
I didn't realize it resets us up.
Thank God.
Oh, I really need that.
I actually really need that.
That is actually so good for me.
I want to kill him.
God, it takes me 20 years to kill this cat.
It takes so long.
It's so laggy, so tanky.
I might need more damage.
I may or may not need more damage.
Maybe.
Alright.
Bigger bone and bigger bullets.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so weak.
Knock back.
At least the knockback will give me a bit more time.
Where is he?
He's like below me, isn't he?
Oh, there he is.
I think this is a good time for the magnet now.
Wee!
Alright, gun.
Oh my god, that's good.
That's good.
I just got...
Gun!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
We leave.
Oh my god, we leave so fast.
We leave so fast.
Oh my god, I am so fucking vulnerable.
Run, don't you run?
I am so weak.
This robot is so weak.
He doesn't even have the DPS to fucking make up for it.
For this weak ass.
That's fine.
Everything is fine.
Fly, you fool.
Fly.
I swear to God, it does not.
even his weak ass isn't even worth how is it even worth the dps oh my god oh my god oh then he spots it okay god that never trusts the clankers never trust
where the oh there he is yeah i definitely need a magnet soon oh my god there's some you you actually need that Oh, wait, I really want to grab the nuke.
Oh, is it worth it, though?
Is it worth it?
It might be worth it.
Oh, okay.
Ray.
Oh, my God.
I really want to grab that nuke.
Imagine all the money I could grab down here.
Here it is.
There it is.
Oh, my God.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, shit.
No.
I swear to God, he's made of fucking plastic.
He's so...
I don't like...
I don't like him.
He's so...
He's so fragile.
He's like a glass build or some shit.
Yeah, the greed.
I don't like it.
His build...
He's so fucking weak as hell.
We'll try Robin.
Let's grab some items.
Let's go.
all right i want to be tier three seals from the poor and gives to the rich my man how else would the rich keep getting richer yeah stop my fucking woman that's what we needed i knew robin hood needed an improvement it shoots an arrow that pierces enemies gain one percent gold per level also increases damage slightly by total gold in inventory wait does that mean like if I save more money I do more damage or is it more like overall gold I collect guys can you he wields the what was it it's do I have to have the money in my inventory throughout or more like Is it the total amount that I...
Holy look at his aura.
Stops damage and...
Alright, you know what?
Let's do...
Yeah, let's do Mega Chat.
Fuck it.
Let's do tier...
We'll do tier 3.
Oh wait, there's a new map.
Wait, I wanna...
Wait, actually...
Restart.
Oh wait, not here.
I clicked the wrong one.
Okay, I just... I just want to see him.
Like, I just wanted to see him.
in because it was such a Chad mood.
A hot... Yeah, I want to try this.
Oh!
Wait, okay.
Let's beat tier 3.
I'd rather beat tier 3 than try the new map.
Bump.
Oh.
Look at me.
Oh my god.
Wait, I think it's the garlic.
Yeah, it is.
That's right.
Bump.
Oh my god.
Look at this Alright, let's...
What do we get?
I don't...
Do we want any of these tomes?
Or should we... What build do we...
Yeah, he's literally aura farming.
Is that size build?
Do we do a size build?
Aura farming is real.
Damn.
That's right.
Gotta keep it up.
up all right we got fine that's looking right you can't handle this aura you can't touch this aura farm plus i don't know this is so silly i love it all right oh i'm a little bit faster now i'm brisk walking
i don't i'm not even i don't i don't think we need projectile.
Let's just keep focusing on aura.
Alright.
No weapons only aura.
The aura must grow.
Oh my god, size.
Wait, does size increase the aura?
I can't tell.
Is it increased?
Did it get, did my aura get bigger?
You think my aura grew bigger, guys?
That's right, they wish they were me.
Oh my god, I flexed!
I actually started...
I don't know if crit...
Does this do crit?
I can't tell.
Size matters now.
Do I want...
Wait, does it...
Does aura give crit?
Aura?
Okay, we just keep going.
Never stop.
Aura farming.
I don't even know what would go well with aura.
What?
Oh, the aura.
That's right, can't touch me.
You have to have a specific type of aura.
The fucking flex.
That's fucking right.
Get over here, skeleton.
Max 40% the faster I move.
Aura.
Oh wait, I should have got the damage.
Oh well, it's too late.
This is more important.
I can just stand there and you can't touch me.
I feel like knockback would be good, right?
Yeah.
There's no way knockback is included with this.
Does this give knockback?
I don't think it does.
Oh, it doesn't.
Okay, I wasted it.
I don't know if it does.
Pickup range.
I feel like pickup range so when the more aura I have.
Uh...
Like, if I have, like, a lot of aura, at least I can pick everything up.
Oh my god, this is it.
This is a...
I'm doing it.
I'm theory crafting.
Am I just standing still?
Oh, it does knock.
It's so hard to tell.
But...
I'm not going to be greedy here.
That's right.
Oh, that is not good.
Size, tome, or death?
Oh, maybe damage tome or aura.
Damage or damage tome or aura.
Let the aura work for me.
What?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, guys.
I might need to be a little faster, though.
I didn't have to do more damage or be just a little bit.
I need life steal.
I think life steal would be so good for this.
Yeah, I need lifesteal really badly.
Yeah, to make this work, we need lifesteal.
Oh my god, speaking of lifesteal.
Ask and ye shall receive.
Let's go.
Nice.
We actually needed that.
Alright, that's right.
Stand near me.
You wish you could be as cool as me.
Oh, wait.
Flame Walker might be good, too.
Because, like, Or, Aura.
Barely outspeeding the...
Okay.
You're right.
Why would I ever doubt Aura?
I feel like I need speed.
I might be a little too slow.
Shield.
Projectile.
I'll refresh.
Oh, wait.
Wouldn't chunkers be good with my build?
Right?
Because it's rock and aura.
Alright.
I just need to speed tome.
I think if I have a speed tome, it'll be really good.
So I like those who are like maybe too strong like these guys.
Like these guys.
Yeah.
I'm gonna try to find a speed tome.
And a size tome too.
Yeah, speed and size.
All right, more raw.
Okay, this should be fine because...
Oh, size!
Size!
Size tome!
All right, size tome, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's make it bigger.
um hp uh chunky chunky rock okay we gotta go grab our oh my god look at this too much aura oh my god there we go too much aura can't get near me now they can't handle it oh shit does so much Okay, I want to see if the shady guy is selling anything good.
I need speed, though.
Damage.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I could skip and try and find.
Guys, should I skip or try and find speed?
Or take the damage to him.
Would be worth it.
Okay, skip for speed.
Alright.
I wonder if that gives me more rock.
Or do I do...
I wonder if this gives me another extra rock.
Yeah?
Alright, we'll get more.
Oh, it does.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
A lot of them.
Okay, we're gonna go here.
The only issue is how slow I am.
That's like my only... only great right now.
I'm so slow.
Do check
out more rock.
I just walked so slow.
Yeah, we gotta find... gotta find the boss.
More rock.
There must be something over here.
I'm flexing them away.
I'm walking over here.
He's gotta have something.
Okay, we night- Oh, that's good.
That's actually so good.
Is there anything else here?
What's up there?
Oh, it's a challenge.
Okay.
Get out of here.
Be gone!
Let me flex!
Evasion tome.
Okay, size.
Grab the size.
And then next one, if we can't find the speed, we'll grab the, uh, we'll grab the aura.
Holy shit.
This, this is bad.
I've yet to find, I've yet to find a single, uh, a mag, I have not found a magnet or a speed tome.
And that's like what we need right now.
That's right.
Be gone.
You have no, you don't have enough aura to be near me.
That's fucking right.
Bigger.
Oh my god, I flexed fall damage too.
That's right.
Oh, there you go.
I found the boss.
That's fucking right.
Fall damage has nothing on me.
Flex the fall damage.
That's how good I am.
Okay.
Or HP.
That's always good.
Wow, I slowly head upstairs.
Very slowly.
We're slowly just walking over there.
Just very slowly.
Heading over to the boss.
We're gonna make it.
We're gonna find Spotted or.
Guys.
Are you serious?
Oh, we can't skip.
Fuck.
Okay.
Do we get armor or quantity?
We couldn't get.
Yeah, we couldn't get the speed.
Oh, this sucks.
We got Pywalk.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, the power walk kit.
Alright, guys, it's time.
This is the power walk build.
We're truly aura farming now.
Try to figure out how to get up there.
Holy shit, it's so far up.
Oh my god.
It's even bigger than I expected it to be.
Look at that.
Oh my god, it's on 50% of my...
It's 50% of my screen now.
the slow walk adds to the art oh shit this is great this is actually so good wait i got the wait this is actually this perfect i have a fucking campfire now too okay it's over here where's the where's he that's fuck here get over here you can't handle this that lucky right yeah that's right you can't handle this oh my god maybe he can't wait give me a sec maybe he can't handle this
okay we have this another burger
okay i don't like how it's taking him fucking forever to die okay the worst part is that i actually have not found a single magnet at all this is so bad Actually, let me go.
I'll go walk up.
Fuck it.
Actually, no, I want him to die before I head to the final boss.
Okay, nice.
Guys, I'm trying to.
I'm trying to.
It's... Guys, you don't understand.
It takes so long to walk over there.
You know?
It's just...
It takes you... It's on high, high ground.
My guy don't have enough money, too.
That sucks.
You don't understand.
I've been trying.
I've been trying to walk over to the boss for so long.
He's all the way up here.
I gotta grab this though.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
Okay.
I have to find this from here.
I don't know.
I'm scared.
I'm actually really scared about this one.
This is close.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
There's a magnet here.
That's so good for us.
Grab this.
Aura.
Chunk.
Grab a little armor.
Aura.
There we go.
Uh...
Size!
More aura!
That's so stupid.
okay oh my god he's so i think he's a little faster than me though i think he's just a little bit faster than me look at that aura this is bad he's just a little oh my god armor okay we need that actually protect please protect me 19k holy shit oh my god this has to be the slowest shit Okay,
more rock.
It's fine.
We'll just add more rock.
It's fine
My entire area is literally just or Holy shit It's gonna take a while guys.
I need more damage.
I think I should have invested more in damage guys I might have messed up by not investing in damage Just maybe.
I have so much, but it's taking forever.
The kills.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I don't think I'm
losing.
Oh, there's a burger.
There's a burger I flexed on him.
And there's burgers.
We gotta grab the burgers.
No!
It should have taken the damage.
It's too bad.
Good.
I got greedy.
I'm so greedy to understand.
I needed...
I wanted the burger.
I'm so greedy.
My chat, please.
I want to complete tier three.
I need to do tier three.
Alright.
I had campfire.
Oh my god, I had campfire.
I forgot about campfire.
Alright.
I steal from Napor.
Let's go.
I jumped for the...
the beef, guys.
I was through my attack speed because I'm an archer, right?
What build should I do for Robinette?
I got baited by the burger.
Maybe damage?
Hmm.
Projectile count and attack speed.
Okay.
Uh...
okay what did that projectile okay money build okay you're right we have to grab money too I forgot we don't open chests we gotta be rich it's all about the money all right we gotta start hoarding then I got get like gold build okay projectile more projectile that's good I'm gonna start hoarding I'm gonna find all the the pots too
Wee!
Oh my god, why there's so many shady guys now?
Greed.
More greed, more money.
More money, less problems, right?
That's how it goes, right?
I missed a shot.
I'll come back.
Oh, I found the boss right away.
That's good, too.
Oh, I'm so fast.
I like that.
Oh my god, with gun.
What?
Bo quantity or do I bring a gun to a bow fight?
No, I bring a gun.
Do it?
All right.
We'll start shooting.
We'll bring a gun to a bow fight too.
There you go.
All right, I want to grab the upgrade here.
Okay, I need to focus on just getting money.
Wee!
Double jump.
Oh my god, I want to grab that skeleton, but I feel like Oh, no, I was so close Cool down or damn What do I want again?
Oh, that shoots bullets Do I want cool down or attack speed?
Okay Grab that Okay Come on.
Cool down.
Attack speed.
Nice.
Come on.
Oh my god.
That's what we need.
It's getting projectile speed.
Oh, we got so much.
It's good.
Jeez.
Nice.
Alright.
We just gotta keep hoarding money.
Go, go, go, go.
Go, go.
Okay, attack and projectile.
Let's just keep shooting.
Don't open any chests.
Oh, it's so tempting, though.
Whoa.
That's so tempting.
It's like begging me to open them.
Oh, but then I realized I can't get, like, life skills and stuff, too.
I mean, I can from these, but it's going to be, like, very risky.
eat.
That's always good.
Oh my god, I'm so weak.
Please, does anyone have a burger?
Does anyone have a burger for little ome?
I just need a burger.
Pacor.
Bo.
All right.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that's not fair.
Oh, okay.
I don't like it.
I think, guys, she is very hard.
I can already tell.
You know who was the best one?
Monkey.
I think we gotta get tier three.
I have to get tier three.
I think Monkey has never failed me.
He is truly...
It's time.
We had the best build.
It's time to clap.
Monkey will never disappoint.
Okay, wait.
Alright, let's grab...
Nice thunder god monkey.
Definitely projectile.
Definitely.
No, I...
For sure.
Can't afford it yet.
Almost.
There we go.
Oh, nice.
Okay, movement speed.
Banana stonks.
Alright, nice.
I think the...
I think projectile quantity...
I don't know what else.
What do we...
What tone should we do with the...
With it?
Uh...
Size.
Bigger.
Bigger banana.
They'll grab difficulty.
Bigger banana means stronger monkey.
Projectile speed damage or crit?
One, two, or three?
We gotta make it to tier three.
I wanna be in tier three.
Damage?
Okay, damage.
All right, nice.
There's another one too.
Grab this.
There's a chest.
It's fine.
I'm slowly throwing my banana over.
Oh, crit chance.
Nice.
Okay, I'm getting a little greedy now.
I'm getting impatient.
I would say...
Okay, we could refresh it.
Or...
Get the damage.
Because what else do we need other than quantity?
Do you think damage is enough?
Knockback.
Really?
Okay.
I don't know what else do we need other than quantity.
Maybe projectile speed?
Cool down.
Oh, nice.
We got cool down.
That's actually what we needed.
Okay, we got it.
We got the banana build.
Back to the...
Okay, nice.
Got this.
That was a good refresh.
That was actually so good for us.
Monkey jump now.
Bye.
monkey that's right get reflected oh wait gold do i grab gold do i grab it before it's too late nice do i have enough no usually it's like 200 or some shit so grab here banana ow do we need regen we gotta find a regen here all right it should be regen right come on oh my god there's so many shady guys
crit oh my god where are the regen why is there so many of you there's so many shady guys here it's just all shady men trying to sell me stuff please
don't have enough money oh my god regen we need that Don't have enough money for all these shady men.
Guys, I'm not gonna fight the bush.
I can't...
Oh my god.
It's fine.
We're fine.
We're so healthy.
Go down.
Quantity.
And then we'll do banana next.
We actually need more banana.
There's more... Okay, there's a magnet over here.
That's good.
Oh my god, there's so many magnets actually.
Oh fuck, you're right.
We actually, that's junk actually is so good.
Oh my god, I'm so cold.
Oh my god.
HP regen.
Nice.
You need that.
Okay, we're so strong now.
Look at that.
Get clapped.
Get clapped by the...
Oh shit!
Okay, that's karma.
I didn't think he clapped back.
He died.
I thought when you're dead, you don't clap back monkey ready oh i wish i had my campfire i wish because i missed the campfire so much it was so clutch i could have just sit oh shit nice yay
Yay!
I love being a streamer!
Check her PC.
Yay!
Streamer privilege!
Let's go!
Another one?
Does it do like times two damage?
Like, what the fuck?
Oh no, this is where it, man.
Should be fine, right?
Right, right, guys?
I should be fine.
Why are you sick?
Yeah, we're doing it.
Wait, how about I haven't found the boss yet, I just realized.
I guess I haven't found the boss yet.
That's fine, it's fine.
I gotta find it.
Let me grab this real quick.
Okay.
Do I want thorns or pick up range?
I'm so happy for you.
Pick up?
All right.
Banana will never disappoint me.
I remember the reason why my monkey was so strong too last time was because I had the credit card.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I don't know what to pick here.
Because I was opening so many chests and I kept having, like, damage?
Alright.
But I haven't found, I haven't found, like, the credit card in a while.
And movement speed.
Oh, grab this.
Just, just cause.
I feel like it's fine to grab it.
Oh, did I not grab it?
Oh, fuck, I didn't.
It's because I feel like I killed a lot already.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Okay, lightning staff.
Nice.
Banana.
We'll do cooldowns.
Cooled out.
Lightning.
Quantity.
I see purple.
I think it's good.
Oh, shit.
Life's still a crit.
I feel crit.
It's blue.
Blue means more.
Words.
I'll just sit here.
Yay, campfire!
Oh, we'll do damage.
Damage is always nice.
Oh wait, I'm poor.
How did that happen?
No!
How did I become poor?
Did I...
Did I spend it all?
No.
It's because I spent it all on bananas?
No, that can't be it.
No.
There's no way.
Monkey don't need money.
Monkey only needs banana.
More damage.
Banana is life.
Was that the cursing?
Okay, it is.
That's fine.
Monkey died.
time i don't remember where to where i haven't gone though where am i not gone oh i don't have a lot of time left i need to find my i need to find the boss monkey doesn't understand capitalism oh fun i'm gonna damage the leaves it's purple
banana there you go It's a stupid boss fight.
I'll climb.
I'll find it eventually.
Oh, projectile count.
More projectile.
More projectile is always good.
Uh, blue.
Oh, this is bad.
I still haven't found the...
Where the fuck is it?
Oh!
Please, please.
Oh my god, it's fine.
It's okay.
There's 23.
There was 23 there.
damage.
That's okay.
I'll go this way.
Maybe I'll find it here.
Charging a charge will turn into a healing zone.
Also spawn plus two.
We'll do that.
We're always doing stuff like that.
Go down.
More.
God, I hate the ghost.
The ghost is so, like, what is it?
It's so useless.
I find a ghost one to really use this.
Where the fuck?
Holy shit, there's so many people here.
You know what?
We'll be better if we add more.
Oh my god, there's so many people.
Let's add more.
Where the fuck is the fucking boss room?
Oh no.
I feel like I've been everywhere.
I don't want to fight the ghost.
What's this?
Why is money?
Money time.
Money, money, money.
Money, money.
Oh shit, it's Chuckles.
It's Chuckles the rat.
Oh, goodbye, Chuckles the rat.
I want...
I found everything but the boss.
Oh, there it is.
I found it.
I did it.
Yay.
There's something.
Oh, there's experience.
This is minus 20.
I just boomed, but stopped them.
Let's go.
I'm gaming.
Alright, I think I can fight him now.
I'll fight him now.
Fuck it.
I'm not as strong as last time.
But, like, I think I'm pretty strong.
Alright, nice.
Come play.
a couple.
Watch this.
Come on, Tom.
Come on!
I didn't think you would summon it right in front of me.
Oh my God.
Okay, not gonna lie.
This is so much stronger than than aura farming.
Like, you can't deny this is not stronger.
Oh, oh my God.
Now I okay that's fine now at least i have the credit card now banana i think i can oh my god magnet too we'll get banana ram projectile or farm a little bit because we're here let's farm a little bit here since i can let's find a little bit of that money hurt.
It won't hurt.
Just a little bit.
There you go.
120.
I'm like right next to it so there's no way it can just kill me.
Right?
There's no way.
Surely it won't, right?
Just I'm literally right next to it.
So like if things go very, very wrong, don't worry.
Do not worry.
If things go very wrong.
okay nice banana ram surely right I saw a farm this here though oh my god I'm going in I'm going I saw like a giant crowd forming around me and I knew I knew it was my time to go I can do I was playing with fate okay more shroud not doing the green I I think when you're on the second map,
I can't do the green.
Okay, we gotta find as many upgrades as possible.
Okay, this gives me two more charge stations.
I think crit damage.
Okay, we got five more.
Oh, but first, a chest.
Oh, fuck, I'm poor.
Never mind.
No chest.
Okay.
man.
Wait, there's gold.
Wait, I've never seen the gold one before.
I don't know if I have high... Wait, what does this give me?
That has to be OP.
We'll light up some smores.
Oh my God.
Okay, we have... Oh, fuck.
I don't think gold is that important.
Ah, okay, the thing is?
Oh, this is hard.
Because, like, um, more gold, I can open more chests.
I can open more chests, and then I can get more damage upgrades.
But then I also, there's also HP regen.
Uh, I'll go with regen.
I'll go with regen.
I didn't want to go with regen.
Oh, I'll go with regen, just in case.
I can maybe farm, maybe I can farm the gold.
Maybe.
Maybe I'll find another one that does gold.
Oh, I don't know if I made a bad choice there.
I'm just thinking like, I'm thinking like, I can open more chests so that...
Wait, what?
Wait, okay, we gotta get that.
Wait, how much was that?
Thousand, okay, that's fine.
Go save that.
That's a lot of damage.
Okay, I gotta grab this.
That's so much damage, too.
Okay.
Uh...
I don't care about silver enough.
I don't think it's worth it for me.
Compared to everything else.
I'd rather focus on the now, you know?
I'll focus on the now rather than like...
Lightning.
Uh...
Okay, nice more XP.
More XP is always good.
you're so close
okay there he is again with this 58 point ooh size bigger banana oh my god oh my god thank god I have regen holy shit he did so much what the fuck I didn't think he would do that much damage to me that's actually crazy he did so much oh my god not again oh my god it's the same color as this
okay projectile speed projectile speed's good i need like a thousand four hundred holy shit he's so strong he's so fucking strong pull down i've been shocked Get jacked the dokey.
Okay, nice.
More regen.
Oh, is it?
Was it this guy?
No, okay.
I still have to save up.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Nice.
Quick damage.
Oh!
Oh, I didn't realize he they would do so much.
I didn't realize.
Oh, my God.
I did not realize they were going to do that much.
Okay, we just got run.
It's fine.
We have regen.
Attack speed or damage, chat?
The goblin storm is here.
One or three.
Or speed.
I don't know.
I don't know if speed is good.
Three?
Okay.
I don't know.
That's the thing.
I can't tell if speed would be a good investment.
Oh my god, we have enough.
I don't know where he lives.
I forgot where he lives!
Where did that guy live?
Oh my god.
Banana.
Where did he live?
Oh, what a new music.
I don't remember.
He was near some cliffs.
Oh, that's so tough.
At least I'll grab the chest first.
Where's East?
You think I know where East is?
Oh, my God.
Is it him?
This is you.
No!
It's not him!
I don't know where he is.
lives please I have so much money please let me spend my money I might as well spend it here fuck it let me spend my money sir oh
my god I'm so lost all I see are just these tombs i saved up so much that's it i'm grabbing double jump
i saved up so much money for him banana
maybe he's like over there oh
there you go luck i don't think i need another jump does he live here he doesn't live Where the fuck does he live?
Where does he live?
Where's your home?
Oh my god, I'm grabbing the magnet, though.
Was it you?
Oh my god, I already talked to you.
I already talked to this guy.
Maybe it's him.
I think it's him.
I think it's this guy.
I think it's him God You all look the same You all look
Oh my god I found the boss though at least You know there's little things I found the boss at least guys Look at that He's just fine I want to buy that one It's not the same
Okay Oh my god of course it gave me this Wait, how much?
Oh, my God, I wasted that.
God damn it.
I wasted all my money.
I swear to God, if I find him, I swear to God, if he shows up now after I wasted all my money, I swear to fucking guy, I will find his family.
I'm still trying to find this man.
I don't know where he lives.
I feel like I try.
Oh, my God, is it him?
is it him it was I it was him I'm staying here I don't care I need it this is where I get my money how much was it I didn't see I forgot to check how much it was it cost more are you fucking kidding me okay I can find this here I can find this here I swear it I know I can't I gotta farm it Okay,
we gotta kill them too
Okay, lightning Holy shit, he's so tanky Oh my god Guys, I told you guys I'm starting to not believe that I can farm it here anymore I'm starting to Okay, we have to kill the boss though Okay, guys, remember this area I'm gonna summon the box I have to summon him we gotta at least activate the boss just in case just in case just in case we gotta oh my god you fucking kidding me there was a currency thing there was a currency thing right here there
was a currency thing right here i'm using life still i'm using life still oh my god almost that i almost that i almost that i almost that This is not good.
This is actually not good for me.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I don't know if I could kill him.
I do so little damage.
He has 600k.
Why does he have 600k?
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
Okay.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Guys, we might be a little fuck.
We might be a little fuck.
We...
Just a little bit.
It's just a teensy little, teensy little bit.
Oh no.
Oh no, we didn't have enough time.
Why?
Where did this get so hard?
Oh no, why did this get so hard?
Why the fuck did this get so hard?
cool down oh my god oh my god where is the big boss there he is there he is there he is there he is but I don't think I'm living I don't think I'm living oh I am guys I'm not even 50% done I'm not I don't have enough damage I actually just don't have enough damage oh this is so bad oh my god at least let me have this at least let me have this I don't have enough damage I don't...
Shit!
Oh, my god!
I'll never get the tier three!
No!
Oh!
Stop.
I needed more damage.
Make them skill-ish.
I wanna get the tier three!
Oh!
I need to upgrade banana more.
Okay, is I... Do I focus on banana upgrades?
Okay, there's fire blades.
Poor monkey.
I'm a very poor monkey now.
All right, we focus on banana.
I need damage.
Okay.
All right, we got this.
Back to monkey.
I believe...
Guys, I don't think...
aura would clutch this.
Okay.
We focus on banana.
Banana's the key.
I'll do glee here.
Can't embrace it.
Aura would absolutely not clutch it and you know it.
Alright.
Speed.
Projectile speed.
Banana.
Projectile speed and What else?
What tome do we do again?
Damage?
Where did the monster?
Oh, there he is.
And damage.
Do we do projectile speed and damage tome then?
Okay.
Damage tome might help.
Oh, bloody tome!
I don't know.
Nah, it's not worth it, right?
Yeah, we'll do boomerang.
Let's just focus on banana.
Banana strong.
Silver Tome.
Firestaff.
Refresher now.
Is Firestaff good or should we just refresh it?
Refresh.
Alright.
Oh, projectile speed.
That's good, right?
Or do we skip?
Uh, or banish.
We could banish, we'll banish Flamewalker.
Projectile speed?
Is it worth it?
Alright.
Okay, it's either we get...
Okay, since we have projectile speed, we have to either get cooldown, which is worth more.
Quill down or damage, chat.
What do you think was worth more?
I don't know if I should do damage tome or, uh, cool.
that oh my god i got 3d oh wait that's the fastest run oops oh i got a shop though let's go guys look it's weird i got a shop it was guys it was calculated i got a shop guys i got it guys it was calculated now i have shop now i have we did it yeah Um,
we'll do this.
Or...
No, it's not.
Guys, it's not the plan.
Banana has given...
Has clutched me so far.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
This is a good area.
Wait, this is...
Wait, I'm literally surrounded by upgrades.
Wait, what the fuck?
That's crazy.
I'm gonna mess up this RNG or not.
Oh, 100%.
I'm gonna fuck it up.
Knock back.
Grab this.
And we have the boss area, too.
Thank God.
Banana.
Uh...
Movement speed or...
Uh, one or three?
Should I be faster or more projectile?
Three?
Okay.
Oh my god, we're actually surrounded by upgrades right now I'll come back to you later because I don't have money And then
Regen Reflect Kakumba stomped Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, no, no, no, no, no, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa Cool down You need that
I think jumping actually has helped us a bit more.
Okay, beer.
Nice.
B.O.
Claw.
I don't mean that.
I'm trying so hard not to be greedy.
Alright.
We have cooldown.
We get damage tome or refresh and try to get...
get projectiles home.
Damage?
Alright, we'll go damage then.
God, I stupid fucking hate the ghost.
The ghost does, like, absolutely nothing for me.
I feel like if we get the credit card, it'll be so good for us.
Grab the extra jump.
Forbidden, Jews.
Nice.
It's extra forbidden.
okay what's that currency time i'm gonna save that i'm gonna save that for this war so i can be rich
movement speed
pack speed wait that's xp we gotta grab the xp the xp boy xp boy get back here xp boy get your ass back here okay nice okay it uh refresh maybe i don't know what wait cheese is super good for it okay we'll grab cheese next refresh or is bone is bone actually omp oh bone benefits from the same upgrades okay i'll grab bone all right now it's bone zone again here.
I gotta remember the magnet.
Banana.
You know what?
No.
I thought about it and the risk is too high.
But I thought about it and I remember it was not a good time.
I was like, how bad could it be?
And I was like, no, it was so bad.
It was so bad.
It was like, no, actually it was very bad.
Yeah.
I mean, more stuff.
Bone, banana.
One, two, or three.
Do we just... One?
Oh, you mean the last one?
We go with cooldown?
But what if it... No, it was not a good... I remember.
I thought he had a gun, guys.
You know what I have?
I just have bananas.
He had a fucking gun, and all I had was a banana.
I feel like Boss Buster would be really good.
Boss Buster would be really good against the big ones.
Yeah.
Because I struggle the most against them.
We'll have to remember there's a magnet here too.
Okay, where is he?
How much damage do I do?
Thank God.
Just need more like projectiles or cooldowns.
See this.
There you go.
Dresson and Dean, 30% of their max HP every second.
Okay, that's good.
Damage.
Oh, money, money, money.
Give me your money.
Your deficit make me rich.
That is your purpose.
Your purpose is to give me money.
I'm gonna break all the pots.
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna grab the magnet after this.
Alright.
One, two, or three, chat.
Capitalism hit monkey.
What happened to you, monkey?
Monkey.
used to be so happy when it's just... Oh, wait, did I grab?
Oh, okay, I grabbed it.
Okay, I...
Used to be so happy when it's just banana.
What happened to you?
Capitalism hit monkey hard.
Monkey, now part of capitalism.
Oh, I don't know if that's...
I don't know if this is good.
I feel like one would be better Yeah, I feel like clacking cheeks would be better.
It hasn't failed me yet.
Oh my god, wait, we need to grab the...
Can we go here?
Grab this.
Okay, because I already have a jump.
I know I have currency right there.
I'm grabbing it.
Where is it?
It's like, oh, all the way over there.
No, it's so far.
Oh, nice.
reflect.
Oh, no.
Okay, we'll grab this too.
I know I left like the quarantine shit here.
There you go.
I see it.
We'll grab bone.
Bone.
This bone is so weak.
Cool down.
Bone.
Bone weak.
Okay, now damage.
And then we'll do banana next.
There you go.
Wait, did I kill all of them accidentally?
Hey, where did all the cobblets go?
I need my money!
Money can buy more banana!
Okay, nice.
Banana.
Okay, let's go back.
I'm gonna grab more upgrades.
But can I afford anything from him?
Nice.
Okay, that was nice.
We got this early.
That's so good for us.
That's actually so good for us.
Bone?
I can kill these guys fast.
A forbidden juice.
If it's so forbidden, why make me so strong?
Take that, science.
speed.
They increase damage.
I need to be so OP.
I need the credit card.
I really need the credit card.
I think the credit card would be the thing that makes or breaks this run.
It will go to the...
Oh my god, is there anything else here?
That grab area is pretty possible.
There's so many chests, but I'm so poor.
I need good credit.
Monkey needs good credit.
What to do?
Won't a bank loan monkey more money?
Monkey wants to afford home.
Whoa.
There's a lot of damage there.
Monkey.
needs loan for home so monkey can stockpile banana one or three chat region or size bigger bone and bigger banana monkey wants cards so he doesn't have to jump
monkey's so tired i will focus on damage to him after do this.
I think, like, the boss is, like, I can do that in, like, two minutes.
Uh, increased damage.
is always good.
Jump or evasion?
Monkey needs retirement plan.
One?
Alright.
I think it sucks that I can't, uh, Okay.
Okay.
That sucks.
I actually have not found a single...
I have not found a single credit card.
I think it's too late.
I don't think I'll be finding a credit card anytime soon.
Banks all reject monkeys attempt to get loan.
Monkey sad.
Okay, there's shit.
Oh, nice.
I didn't see his chest.
Oh, cheese.
That's always good.
Alright, I think we can do this now.
Go down.
Okay, we need to invest in...
Cool, never mind.
I was gonna say, we're gonna...
Oh, banana.
Banana?
Damage?
I want to do damage, but...
Blue.
Damage.
I know we didn't get money here.
Legendary banana?
The banks will regret this.
Now I have legendary banana.
They will regret messing with monkey.
Now monkey will be rich with big banana.
Are you fucking kidding?
Oh, mock.
Okay, now I have chest.
It's fine.
Now I have chest.
That's good.
It's fine.
five chests.
That's five.
Oh my god, Spend already spent so much money.
Legendary!
Eat so much.
Oh my god, nice.
We have mega crit.
That's so good for us.
That's actually so good.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, oh my...
Okay, we do a lot of damage now.
Okay, banana.
Alright, we need to...
Okay, I'm gonna try and, like, I need to upgrade bone.
I feel like I should upgrade bone now.
Okay, so final swarm incoming.
Oh my god, there's, like, stuff here.
I have to...
Oh my god, another credit card.
More damage, then.
There's, like, something...
Oh my god, it's a shady man.
Fuck, I'm broke.
Oh, wait, that's actually good.
More damage.
Okay, I can farm a little bit here.
Just a little bit, but I gotta get close to the exit.
Damage.
Okay.
I could stay here and farm just a little bit before they decided to fuck me up.
Just a little bit.
I can grab him.
Let's grab this too.
Okay.
I think it's like a minute before the big boys, the scarier boys come in.
Alright.
Next upgrade we'll focus on bone.
Oh, my God.
They're all coming.
I'm gonna put the shield on just in case.
Whoa.
I go now.
My people need me.
These are my GMO bananas.
I really need to upgrade my, uh, I need to, upgrade my bones, though.
I think bones need the most upgrades.
Luck or size?
Am I gonna get lucky today?
Up on night to get lucky.
I see more luck.
Okay.
We'll grab luck then.
Alright.
We ain't stopping until we get tier 3.
This is so... This is actually so addicting.
Guys, I like...
I- nah, I understand.
I understand.
Okay, nice.
Yeah, more luck.
Oh, chest.
Wait, what the fuck was- Oh, I can open chest for free.
I was like, what?
Oh, we don't grab that.
do we need this I was like what the fuck does the key do that's good yeah I need max HP okay forbidden juice we need 400 oh luck or size
or gold we should get gold no we should get gold so we can open more chests you share share It's rare, but it's okay, you're right Toki it's you're right I'm I'm I'm very easily peer pressure blue No, you guys can peer pressure me so so well Oh attack speed we need that actually I was like you know what what I said earlier You're right
Who cares what I don't have free will.
Silly me.
Okay.
Uh, we need movement speed?
Should we just...
I don't think so.
If I see another movement speed, I'll get it.
I get it.
I personally don't think we need it right now.
Okay.
I have to find the big boss with five minutes left.
Alright.
Okay.
Elite's the big boss?
Or are they the one with the crowns?
The crown enemies?
I don't know if it's worth it.
I'll try.
I personally don't know if that's worth it.
okay there's uh wait what oh there he is oh my god i have two thousand dollars what the fuck
oh nice we need that actually
nice electric plug okay nice i didn't have to buy that i feel like i need to find a magnet like quick
magnet okay nice we got that we definitely need a magnet though it's over we really need a magnet oh i have so much xp just lying there they're just it's just oh my god oh my god to kill the boss i have to kill the boss he does too much damage Where is he?
Check that speed.
Where the fuck is he?
Oh, there he is.
I have to kill him.
Oh, he does so much damage.
And I barely have any life.
I just realized I don't have life still.
Don't wonder.
Don't wonder he does so much.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Oh, oh.
Okay, run.
monkey scared monkey has no life still monkey barely has life still monkey fucked up oh my god I don't feel lucky I don't have gap fire this is one of the rare runs where I don't have gap fire I should summon more enemies you know what this These more enemies.
Oh my god.
I have a giant ass banana now.
4k gold.
I'm trying.
Okay, there's a chest.
I was like, I'm trying.
I'm trying to find all the...
Where did all the chest go?
Oh my god.
Nice.
Wait, we got another legendary.
Okay.
Okay, we need $2,000.
Okay, there's chest here.
Oh my god, there's a gold chest.
Okay, it's movement speed.
Oh my god, okay.
I need to find a magnet so badly.
Cheese.
Banana!
Are there zero magnets here?
Okay.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, thank you.
Streamer privilege.
Let's go.
Yay.
Streamer privilege.
I love streamer privilege.
Death's in the...
chat the devs heard they were actually lurking
okay nice more crit more crit is always good all right let's go to the boss now because i i don't know if i can i i think i'm like so weak i'm strong but i'm so weak right now That's, like, what I'm scared right now.
Okay.
This time, this time.
I'm so weak, though.
I'm, like, so, like, unhealthy.
That's the only issue.
I'm so...
I'm so not healthy right now.
I do a lot of damage.
I will agree.
But he does one damage to me, And I fucking will pass out.
I will.
Speaking of passing out.
Shit.
I told you.
He does.
He touches me once.
It's over.
It's actually over.
If he touched me.
That's what I'm most scared about.
Oh no.
Not the fucking.
Really?
Okay.
This is a bit bad though.
The swarm is coming.
And I'm a little scared.
Because I do not have a lot of life steal.
I have to run.
I don't have a lot of life steal, so I'm very scared.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, as long as I...
Oh my god.
I jump.
Oh, he's dead.
He's dead.
Oh, he's fucking dead.
Banana.
Uh...
Damage.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Yeah, I have to go to the portal.
Oh, I have to go to the portal.
I have to go to the portal.
Where's the portal?
Where is it?
Oh, wait, bud.
Oh, wait, chest.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Let us just stay here a little bit far, little be a little silly be just a little silly all right okay all right what do we focus on for upgrades chat what should we focus on anyway oh oh be just a little silly surviving all right we have to actually we do have to focus on bone a little bit Attack speed,
life...
Okay.
Attack speed, life steal, and bone.
All right.
That's fine.
Okay.
All right, we leave.
We leave.
I tested my luck enough.
Life steal and bone.
Oh, this is scary.
This seems like a...
This does not seem like a place that monkeys should be in.
This...
Um...
I don't think monkey is supposed to be here.
Uh-oh.
I need an extra jump.
I think, like, the jump has been helping me a lot.
I could grab armor.
Alright, next time I see armor, I'll grab it.
Okay.
Nah, three jumps.
Yay!
Monkeys now in doom.
Yeah.
We're in doom now.
Life steal.
Okay, that's what we need.
Holy fuck, thank god.
Alright.
Gotta grab this.
Oh, we have to grab as many upgrades as possible.
I'll try.
Oh.
Two or three.
Three?
Should we grab three?
I need to kill these guys for chest.
Chest is always good.
Holy shit, they're so tanky.
All right, more gold.
Okay, I'm gonna save that magnet.
We're gonna save it.
Nice crit.
quit is always nice all right oh my god they just kept following me okay stone golem 582 k hp oh my god i better do enough damage oh my god please nice oh hp regen Oh my god, he almost one shot me.
He actually almost one shot me.
Oh my god.
Oh That's not good His his attack actually almost one shot me.
That's crazy Oh, that was not good.
That did not feel so good.
I I did not feel good about that Oh My god at.
Please let me grab this.
Okay.
That does not bring me joy.
That absolutely does not bring me joy.
Get him away from me.
Oh my god, I have to kill him first.
I have to kill this guy.
Thank god.
Oh, thank god.
Give me this.
Because that's fine.
That's fine.
He's dead.
He can't hurt me no more.
Yeah, maybe I can grab this before y'all come just for me.
Maybe I can grab this.
Okay, one, two, or three, chat.
It's the goblin.
Three?
Okay.
Wait, I'm gonna grab magnet.
I think it's time.
I know where the magnet is.
I don't, but like...
I like to think I know where it is.
Oh.
size oh my god i found the portal nice okay oh my god it's the stone hedge man
yes oh my god where's the port where is it where's the magnet here i grab this projectile oh my god where the fuck is that magnet i don't remember Okay, do this for the chest.
We need the chest.
Oh, Michael, where did I leave it?
Where did I leave the magnet?
I thought I knew!
I lied!
I lied.
I don't know where the magnet is.
Oh, my God.
We have to do the boss, too.
Of course, the sword comes in.
I said that.
Oh, this sucks.
This sucks because there's so much.
I know I left so many power-ups, too.
Oh, this sucks.
This sucks.
I don't know what I'm looking at.
I am.
I'm looking at my map.
I see no magnet.
I just see health.
Okay, it's boss time.
I have to field the boss, though.
Oh, this is so bad.
Oh my god, this is so bad.
Okay, back in.
Nice!
Okay, that's good, that's good, that's good.
Wait, that's not so good.
Damage.
Oh my god, I can't see anything.
Wait, I can almost afford this.
No, no, he cannot do this to me.
Okay.
No, he cannot fucking do this to me.
Why did you have this?
Oh my god, okay, I have to summon him.
I don't care.
I have to summon him.
Okay, this is...
Where am I?
Oh, shit.
Oh, I didn't realize I've been in a whole new world.
Oh, fuck, okay.
Okay, I didn't know.
7.8 million.
What do you mean?
Where's my banana?
Guys, hey, look.
39,000 in the work.
Okay.
We got, we, technically we beat tier three.
We got transported.
I take those.
I'm not, I'm not.
I don't know.
I don't even know what happened.
It just transported me and then I was gone.
I was just gone.
I don't know what happened to me, guys.
What the fuck happened?
Alright, let's just...
Maybe him skill issue?
I'll take it.
Fuck it.
That's fine.
Let me...
I'm gonna spend...
That was a good attempt.
That was fun.
Honestly, I had a lot of fun playing this.
Yeah, he sneezed on me and I was just dead.
I don't think there was anything else I could do.
He literally just, he just was like, achoo, and then I died.
Like, I died.
I mean, but, yeah, it was very addicting.
A lot of things in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Monkey made a banana.
rip up like oh my god yeah honestly this is very addicting i can see now why a lot of people are spent are like investing like so many hours on it like right off the bat and uh and i didn't unlock a lot see like i barely unlocked half the roster too um and like there's a second map see like look there's i don't know how many maps are there but like there's like three tiers and there's a second map too um so i feel like i've just i'm at the just like um like i just did like 10 of the content uh of this stream um but it's definitely very fun i really i'm not sponsored by them i really but i had so much fun um yeah i feel like i just scratched the surface on this for this game and uh i feel like you could do there's so much to do wait oh my god could be blue monkey but i'm poor honestly i think like default monkey is the best monkey Honestly,
I think Monkey is the strongest.
I think, like, I read the reviews and people were saying, like, if you run speed build on calcium, like, like, you're unstoppable.
You're just too fast.
But right now, from all the characters I unlocked, apparently this guy is the meta, but all the characters unlocked, Monkey seems the strongest for me.
But I hope you guys had a fun time watching.
I know how long we, I didn't intend to, I never expected to stream this long.
I just got, I didn't think I get this addicted, but it's very addicting.
It's very addicting, and I think aura, no, aura, okay, he might have aura, but he was the hardest to play.
Because I, unless I have a speed build, I think, like, like, I felt like I was not doing enough damage.
I felt like my damage was so shit.
Anyway, guys, I hope y'all have fun watching.
I'm gonna head off relax a bit relax now because I have a lot of streams this week and I didn't think I was gonna stream this long but I got hooked this game is so addicting so it hooked I didn't I can't believe four hours have almost five hours have passed but anyway guys as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that blood flow if you stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it I'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye